foreign
Microsoft Azure formerly known as
Windows Azure is Microsoft's public
cloud computing platform that provides a
broad range of cloud services to help
businesses manage challenges and meet
their organization goals
it offers tools that support all
Industries including e-commerce finance
and various Fortune 500 companies what
does actually Azure do and what can it
provide for your business
well this is what I'm here for in this
video on Azure full course I'll take you
through all the necessary and
interesting Concepts and components of
azure and show you the value of azure
for your businesses and the real
benefits you can gain today in this full
course you will first explore what is
azure and the basics of azure you will
also be familiarized with its console
for a more in-depth experience then you
will learn about its provided services
and components like Azure machine
learning Azure active directory Azure
data Factory Azure virtual machines and
Azure virtual Network in detail and with
proper Hands-On demonstrations for a
better understanding in the end you will
see a quick comparison of azure with AWS
and gcp to give you a better perspective
on the individuality of these popular
cloud computing platforms and how Azure
differentiates itself from them by the
end of this video I can assure you that
all your Azure related Concepts and
doubts will have been cleared for this
training with me I have our experience
Cloud Azure specialist together we'll
walk you through the important Azure
Keynotes so let's start with an exciting
video on Azure full course
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn hi guys this is Raul from Simply
learn and today we'll be talking about
one of the fastest growing and second
largest cloud computing platform in the
market right now I'm talking about
Microsoft Azure now before we begin
let's talk about what we'll be covering
in this video first we'll talk about why
you should be interested in cloud
computing what exactly is cloud
computing what is Microsoft Azure some
of its services and the uses of azure
now let's start with why you should be
interested in cloud computing now let's
say you have an idea for a revolutionary
application an idea that ticks both the
boxes when it comes to good applications
one it has great user experience and two
it will be highly profitable now for it
to be successful you'll have to release
it on the internet people need to use it
they need to spread the word and then
it'll become truly famous however for
that you're going to need servers
storage Developers a dedicated Network
an application security to ensure your
application works the way it does now
these are a lot of components and that's
where the problem lies there are two
major disadvantages to this approach the
initial setup is very expensive and
risky which means this requires a huge
amount of capital upfront to ensure that
it works properly and the downside is if
your application does not become famous
or it doesn't return as much as you
expect it to you're probably not going
to get the money back which means it
provides a huge amount of risk and then
on the flip side if it does become
famous the number of users have
increased which means that you'll have
to buy more servers and storage systems
to keep up with your demand and this
problem can be solved with the help of
cloud computing now that you know why
you should be interested in cloud
computing let's go into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources and this is possible
with the help of the internet now as you
user all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop or
your computer through the internet of
course connect to that cloud service
provider and then there you go you have
access to Computing resources now
Computing resources may include you know
serverless Computing virtual machines
storage and so much more now let's dig a
Little Deeper now basically these cloud
service providers actually have massive
data centers now in these data centers
what you have are hundreds of servers
also included are storage systems and
mainly several organizations critical
components so these are very secure safe
locations where a large amount of data
is stored hence the name data centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to collect their
data or use it so actually users can
access any service based on their
requirement now like I told you there's
a number of services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you you
get an email you need a copy of it
created now for all of this there are
services and most importantly almost
every cloud service provider has this
option where users only pay for the
service that they use so there's no
charge up front where they tell you that
you need to pay x amount of money so
that you can use our services you're
only paying for the amount of time that
you're using these Services now cloud
computing is used for a wide variety of
reasons firstly there's machine learning
and data analysis now basically there
are services that analyze your data and
tell you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage and
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on Netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and you browse
through Netflix and you get access to
the videos these are possible with the
help of cloud service providers this
creating and testing applications
automating software delivery which is a
component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications so now what is azure
what's the big cloud service provider
all about so Azure is a cloud computing
platform provided by Microsoft now it's
basically an online portal through which
you can access and manage resources and
services now resources and services are
nothing but you know you can store your
data and you can transform the data
using services that Microsoft provides
again all you need is the internet and
being able to connect to the Azure
portal then you get access to all of the
resources and their services in case you
want to know more about how it's
different from its rival which is AWS I
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the AWS versus SEO
video so that you can clearly tell how
both these cloud service providers are
different from each other now here are
some things that you need to know about
Azure if it's launched in February 1st
2010 which is significantly later than
when AWS was launched it's free to start
and has a pay-per-use model which means
like I said before you need to pay for
the services you use through Azure and
one of the most important selling points
is that 80 percent of Fortune 500
companies use Azure Services which means
that most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using Azure and
then Azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the C sharp
node.js Java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now Azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about Azure Services now Azure Services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute a machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that Azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute Services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of Linux or Windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add RAM you can decrease RAM you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a matter of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by Azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by Azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azure CDN or the content delivery
Network now the Azure CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express
route now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
Microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual Network now with
virtual Network you can have any of the
Azure Services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have Azure DNS so Azure
DNS is a hosting service which allows
you to host their DNS or domain name
system domains in Azure so you can host
your application using Azure DNS now for
these storage Services first up we have
this storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing HDD or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include Text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
manage file storage and can be
accessible via the SMB protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
Azure can be used firstly for
application development which could be
any application mostly web applications
then you can test the application see
how well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate In
Sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data Works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and your virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where they data can be stored
I'm Sam and Azure Cloud architect
working for simply learn and I'm more
than glad to walk you through this
session where we're going to talk about
Azure in great length and breadth and
without any further delay let's get
started everybody likes story is it so
let's get started with the story in a
city not so far away as CEO had plans to
expand his company globally and called
one of his ID Personnel for an I.T
opinion and this guy has been in the
company for a long time and is very
seasoned with the company's infra and he
nicely answered the questions with what
he foresaw and he said I have a good
news and a bad news for us to go Global
and he starts with the good news he said
sir we're well on our way to become one
of the world's largest shipping company
and the bad news is however our data
centers have almost run out of space and
setting up new ones around the world
would be too expensive and very time
consuming now the IT personnel let's
call him Mike now he explains the
situation from how he saw it but the CEO
had done some homework about how he was
going to do it and he answered Mike
saying don't worry about that Mike I've
come up with a solution for a problem
and it's called Microsoft Azure well
Mike is an hard-working and honest I.T
professional working for that company
but he did not spend time on learning
the latest Technologies and he asked
this question very honestly oh how does
it solve a problem and the CEO begins to
explain Azure to Mike and he starts with
what is cloud computing and then he goes
on and talks about Azure and the service
is offered by Azure and why Azure is
better than the other Cloud providers
and what are the great companies that
uses Azure and how they got benefited
out of it and then he winds it all up
with the use cases of azure so he begins
his explanation saying Microsoft Azure
is known as the cloud service provider
and it works on the basis of cloud
computing now Microsoft Azure is
formerly known as Windows Azure and its
Microsoft's public cloud computing
platform it also provides a range of
cloud services including some of them
are compute analytics storage and
networking we can always pick and choose
from these services to develop and scale
our applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
Cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing Azure services offered by
Azure how is azure are leading when
compared to other cloud service
providers and what are the companies
that are using Azure let's talk about
that in simple terms cloud computing is
being able to access compute services
like servers storage database networking
software analytics intelligence and lot
more over the Internet which is the
cloud with the flexibility of the
resources that we use like anytime I
wanted results I can use one and it
becomes available immediately and
anytime if I wanted a tie-in results I
can simply retire at resource and not
pay for it and we also typically pay
only for the services that we use and
this helps greatly with our operating
cost to run our infrastructure more
efficiently and scale our environment up
or down depending on the business needs
and changes and all the servers and
Storage is and databases and networking
all that are accessed through the
network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the provider's data center
which is azure in this case now we don't
use any physical server or an
on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and VMS you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
Services the other use cases are storing
or using Cloud for storage alone if
there is one thing that ever grows in an
organization is the storage every new
day there is a new storage requirement
and it's very Dynamic it's very hard to
predict and if we go out and buy a big
storage capacity up front until we use
the storage capacity fully at the empty
storages you know we're wasting money on
them so instead I can go for a storage
which scales dynamically that's in the
cloud put storage or put data in the
cloud and pay only for what you are
storing and for the next month if you
have deleted or flushed out some files
or data pay less for it so it's a very
Dynamic storage in the cloud and a lot
of companies are getting benefited from
storing data in the cloud because of its
dynamic in nature and the cost that
comes along with it the cheap cost that
comes along with it and also they give a
lot of the providers like Azure they
give data application for free they
promise an SLA along with the data we
store in the cloud so there's an SLA
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored Azure
automatically makes our data available
from the Redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the
SLA they wanted to keep the other use
case for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music Azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of CDN content
delivery Network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application Azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
softwares embedded softwares that we can
buy using Azure and everything on a pay
as you go service model so anytime we
need a software we can go out and
immediately buy the software for the
next one hour or two hour let's say and
use them and then return it back we're
not bound to any yearly licensing cost
by that Azure Computing Services has
analytic available for us with which we
can analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network beat logs
beat the performance beat the metrics
you know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved Azure analytics
Services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the Azure analytic
Services now cloud is really a very cool
term for the internet a good analogy
would be looking back anytime we look at
a diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a mail gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country the a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the read button right
and we let the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so a cloud is a really
cool term for the internet now that's
some Basics about cloud computing now
that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
Microsoft Azure as a cloud service now
Microsoft Azure is a set of cloud
services to build manage and deploy
applications on a network with the help
of Microsoft azure's Frameworks now
Microsoft Azure is a Computing service
created by Microsoft basically for
building testing deploying and managing
applications and services through a
Global Network of Microsoft managed data
centers now Microsoft Azure provides SAS
which is software as a service and pass
which is platform as a service and IAS
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
Microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management Azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and Enterprise environment it
saves us a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of Microsoft
Azure it was launched on 1st February
2010 and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by a Gartner
now Gartner is the world's leading
research and advisory company this
Microsoft Azure supports a number of
programming languages like c-sharp Java
and python all these School Services we
get to use and pay only for how much we
use for example if we use for an R we
only get to pay for an R even the cost
list system available if you use them
for an R we only pay for that particular
R and then we done no more billing on
the resource that we have used a
Microsoft Azure has spread itself more
than 50 regions around the world so it's
quite easy for us to pick a region and
you know start Pro positioning and
running our applications probably from
day one because the infrastructure and
the tools and Technologies needed to run
our application are already available
all that we have to do is comment the
code in that particular region or build
an application or launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of In
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
requests will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center near each customer location
because of the cost involved but with
Azure it's possible Azure already has
data centers around the world and all
that we have to do is just pick a data
center build an environment there
they're available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably saved because we are using
a public Cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that Azure is offering is ever
increasing as of now as we speak we have
like 200 plus services offered and they
span through different domain or
different platform or different
Technologies available within the Azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure let's now
talk about different services in Azure
starting with artificial intelligence
plus machine learning where we have a
lot of tools and Technologies
so the wide variety of services
available in Azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get and or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute Services different VMS with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us and identity service to
manage our users in the Azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
Federated with let's say Google Facebook
you know LinkedIn so they are some
external Federation Services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iot's iot Services iot tools and
Technologies available and management
tools to manage the users you know
creating identities one and then
managing them on top of it is a totally
different thing and we have tools
Technologies to manage the users cool
services for a data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
Technologies available for mobile
application a development and I can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking Services I can Implement my
own security both Azure provider and
third-party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's say
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the Azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or an on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
Azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment inside azure's Cloud
environment that too in a virtual
private Network now we will talk about
virtual private Network at a later point
but as of now just know that there are a
lot of services available in Azure
compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of compute options for
example you know we have an option to
choose the operating system we have the
option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on-premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
soft were attached to it or do we want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from Azure Marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these computer
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pair for what we use
model meaning there is no upfront cost
we use the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal or long term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a paper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
paper minute bill model at no point we
will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now bad service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or Linux it's going to run fairly well
and with batch servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
Azure batch service is actually runs on
a large scale parallel and high
performance Computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in Azure
and when we run batch services this
Azure batch creates a pool of computer
nodes and installs the needed
applications that we want to run and
then it schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually can use the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and the networking
services that we will be using for this
batch serves let's summarize this batch
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this bad service
helps us to manage the application and
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
to applications that are composed of
microservices no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scales that it lets us to create
a group of identical load balanced VMS I
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced VMS the number of instances or
the number of VM instances in an in a
skill set can increase or decrease in
response to the demand or in response to
a schedule that we Define you know the
resources needed on a Monday morning is
not the same as that would be required
on a Saturday or a Sunday morning all
right and even within the day the
resources that would be needed in the
beginning of the business hour is not
the resources that would be needed now
at noon or you know after eight or nine
in the evening so the demands could
actually vary in their environment and
this skill set helps us to take care of
the varying demand or take care of the
different infrastructure requirement at
a different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
High availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like I said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes other requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machine scale said we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of VMS and it's a great use case
when it comes to Big Data or container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about cloud services
now this Azure cloud service is actually
a platform as a service and it's very
friendly in fact it is designed for
applications that support scalability or
an application that requires scalability
or reliability and and on top of it you
want them to be very inexpensive to
operate so Azure cloud service provides
all these so where would this cloud
service run well it runs on a VM but
it's a platform as a service VMS are
infrastructure as a service and when we
run applications on VM through cloud
service it becomes platform as a service
so here is how you got to be thinking
with infrastructure as a service like
VMS we first create and configure the
environment and then we run applications
on top of it let's look the
responsibility the responsibility for us
in VM is that we manage everything end
to end like uh you know deploying new
patches picking the versions of the
operating system and making sure they
are intact and all that stuff it's all
managed by us but on the contrary with
platform as a service it's I mean it's
as if the environment is already ready
all that you have to do is deploy your
application in it and manage the
platform I mean manage the platform not
as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by Azure
like you know deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all handled by
the Azure so we deploy the application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
Azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can write the application code
and we don't have to worry about
Hardware simply hand over the code and
cloud service takes care of it so no
worry on the the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something crashes how do I
update the infrastructure how do I
manage the maintenance or the downtime
in the underlying infrastructure all
that is handled by Azure it also
provides a good testing environment for
us you know we can simply run the code
test it before it's actually released to
the production I want to expand a bit on
these testing applications so this Azure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging envelope
government where we can add more to it
and then swap it back at a later point
so it kind of gives us in swappable
environment for testing our applications
and not only that it gives us Health
monitoring alerts it helps us to monitor
the health and availability of our
application and there is a dashboard we
can benefit from when we use Azure cloud
services and that shows the key
statistics all in one place and we can
also set up real-time alerts to one when
a service availability or a certain
metrics that we are concerned about D
grades as next thing in compute domain
let's talk about functions now functions
are serverless Computing you know many
times if you heard about Azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
Computing or Azure functions which is a
serverless Computing service hosted on
Microsoft Azure the main motive of a
function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running that code and the
best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what is azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is C Sharp F sharp node.js the Java and
PHP so here we really don't have to
worry about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes Azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in Azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a Docker
swarm cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one Computing
environment to another it could be a
testing to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on premises to
cloud or One Cloud to another Cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the VM and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
allowing the new tools required to
manage the VMS or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers they can be
deployed into the cloud using a single
command if you're using command line
interface and a couple of button clicks
if we are using the Azure portal and
these containers are kept lightweight
but they are equally secure as virtual
machines let's talk about container
service as next thing the container
service or or sometimes called as Azure
kubernetes service it helps us to manage
the containers containers one thing and
a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them now
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that at the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and ACS also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this AKs
helps us to simplify that environment
all right as next thing in content in a
domain let's talk about container
registry we spoke about registry a
little bit when we spoke about Docker
images so container registry is a single
place where we can store our images
which are Docker images when we use when
we use containers it's it's Docker
images that we use for our image
purposes so these container images are a
central registry that can be used to
ease container development by easing the
storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like Docker swarm or the images
used in Docker swarm or in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these Geo replication and it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geo replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images will have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provosting of the applications
Global wide and this replication also
helps us to helps us Network latency
because you know any time an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which which can be
reached only through high latency
Network because we have Global
replications around the world anytime
the application wants to check back it
will check back uh the application which
is in a very nearby location for the
application itself Global replication
means that we are managing it as a
single entity that's being replicated
across the multiple regions in the globe
has next thing in a learning let's talk
about Azure databases now this Azure
databases are a rational in fact they
have many flavors in them we're going to
look at different uh flavors so SQL
nosql cache type of database that Azure
offers so we're going to learn one at a
time or we're going to learn one by one
so this Azure SQL database is a rational
database in fact it's a rational
database as a service it's managed by
Azure we don't get to do a lot of
management in it so it's a rational
database as a service based on Microsoft
SQL Server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very Bible and it's very secure as
well and this High reliability high
performance and for this high security
we really don't have to do anything it
comes along with it and it's managed by
Azure and there are two things that I
definitely need to mention about Azure
SQL database that is it's an intelligent
service number one it's fully managed by
Azure and it also has this one good
thing which is it has built-in
intelligence that learns app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability and data protection of the
application that's something that's not
found in many of the other Cloud
providers that I'm aware of so I thought
I'll mention it so it uses built-in
intelligence to learn about the user's
database patterns and helps improve
performance and protection and migration
or importing data is very easy when it
comes to Azure SQL database so it can be
readily or immediately used for analytic
reporting and intelligent applications
in Azure as next thing let's talk about
Azure Cosmo DB now Azure Cosmo DB is a
database service that is for nosql type
and it's it's created to provide low
latency and an application that scales
dynamically or that scales rapidly now
this Azure Cosmo DB is an a globally
distributed service
and it's a multi-modal database this can
be provisioned in a click of a button
that's all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure Cosmo DB in the
Azure it helps with scaling the database
now we can elastically and independently
scale throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the Azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and it
provides our Azure promises a
comprehensive SLA that no other database
can offer that's the best part about
cosmodb so this Cosmo DB was built with
a global distribution in mind and it's
built with a horizontal scale in mind
and all this we can use by only paying
for what we have used and remember the
difference between Azure Cosmo DB and
the SQL database is that Azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas SQL doesn't
alright few other things about Azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph column family and document
data it also gives users a number of AP
options like SQL JavaScript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check in the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that R alright let's talk
about redis cache discussion about Azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about credit cache now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now redis
cache is based on and a popular open
source caching product which is redis so
sometimes called as there is cash now
what's the use case it's typically used
to Cache to improve the performance and
scalability of a system that rely
heavily on back-end data stores now
performance when we use redis cache is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis Cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as a
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this various cache and by
using various cash the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
height throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this various cache is actually backed by
Reddit server and it supports a string
hashes linked list and various other
data structures now let's talk about
security and identity Services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's a principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the specialty about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide the access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and security accident from happening so
let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity G management or
Azure security center now this Azure
security Center provides Security
Management and threat protection across
the workloads in both cloud and in the
hybrid environment it helps control user
access and application control to stop
any malicious activity if present it
helps us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environment so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
service in security and identity would
be keyboard now a key vault is a service
or a feature that help Safeguard the
cryptographic keys and any other Secrets
used by the cloud applications and the
services in other words this Azure key
vault is a tool for securely storing and
accessing the secrets of the environment
I mean the secret Keys now a secret is
anything that you really want to have a
very tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyword is now key vault is
used in Secrets management it's helped
in securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about the certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy pop public
and private SSL TLS certificates in
Azure and lot more so in a nutshell this
key wall it provides users the ability
to provision new walls and keys in just
a matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloud-based active directory and
identity management service now Azure
active directory combines and it's
actually a combination of the core
directory Services Plus application
access management plus identity
protection and and one good thing about
this Azure in fact there are a lot of
good things but especially when you're
running hybrid environments you might
wonder well how does Azure active
directory is going to behave now this
Azure active directory is built to work
on on-premises and Cloud environment as
well not only that it also works
seamlessly with mobile applications as
well so in a nutshell this Azure active
directory it acts as an central point of
identity and access management for our
Cloud environment it also provides good
Security Solutions that protect against
unauthorized access of our app and the
data now that we've discussed about
security and identity let's talk about
the management tools that Azure has to
offer Azure provides built-in management
and account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on-premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build a disaster
recoveries it also helps in applying
policies and conditions to automate our
environment we use Azure management
tools and it's also used in cost control
methods so this Azure management plays a
wide role across the Azure services and
in the management tools first comes the
Azure advisor now this Azure advisor it
acts as a guide to educate us about
Azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that will happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations or first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not Parts it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provided are very easy
to follow very easy to implement and see
results you can think of azure advisor
as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azura advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps in improve the performance
security High availability of our
environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure use message and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment and next in the list would
be Network Watcher now this network
Watcher helps users identify and gain
insights in the overall Network
performance and the health of the
overall environment now these Azure
Watchers provides enough tools to
monitor to diagnose to view the metrics
and to enable or disable logs which
means regenerate and collect the logs
for resources in the Azure virtual
Network so with network Watcher can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a VM or in a
database you know but just looking at
the logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our Network we can
again a lot of insight to the current
Network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network Watcher offers it also helps in
investigating VPN connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and over and stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the the
list would be Microsoft Azure portal now
this Microsoft Azure portal it provides
a single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using Azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the Azure portal
and this Azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on teams spends based on days
spends based on Department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual offer where the money is spending
or where is the bill consumed within the
Azure environment next in the list would
be Azure a resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual Network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
Azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure results
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision or deploy at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources a
lot better resource Group also is used
to control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools will be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across hybrid environments it provides a
cloud-based Automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non-azure environments as
well which is on-premises so some of the
automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete control during the
deployment operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error-free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
are we going to use the word CDN here
cdns store cached content on global Edge
servers also called as pops point of
presence locations that are very close
to the end users so the latency is
minimized it's like taking a copy of the
data or taking multiple copy of the data
and storing it in different parts of the
world and whoever is requesting it the
data gets delivered to them from a
server which is very locally to them so
this CDN offers developers a global
solution for rapidly delivering high
bandwidth content to users by caching
the content in a strategically placed
location which is very near to them so
these content delivery networks it
really helps in handling that's one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very efficiently and we can
also run analytic against the logs that
gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the results first and
then you only pay for what you have used
the next one in networking would be
expressed route now express route is
actually circuit or a link that provides
an a direct private connection to Azure
and because it's direct it gives low
latency link to Azure it gives good
speed and reliability for the Azure data
transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
in service that actually provides a
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and the infrastructure in
our premises or in a different
co-location facility that we might have
now these Express routes do not go over
the public internet and because they
don't go over the public internet they
offer a high security reliability and
speed and low latency compared to the
connections which are in the the
internet because it's fast because it's
reliable because it has low latency it
can be used as an extension of our
existing data center you know users are
not going to feel the difference whether
they are accessing services from an
on-premises or in the cloud environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible users are really not going to
see the difference and because it's a
private line and not an public internet
line it can be used to build hybrid
applications without compromising a
privacy or at the performance now these
virtual private Cloud these expressed
routes can be used for taking backups if
assume a backup going through the
internet that would be a nightmare if
you use express route for backups that's
going to be fast and imagine recovering
a data through the internet from the
cloud through the internet to the
on-premises in a time of disaster that
would be the worst nightmare so these
Express routes can be used not only to
backup but also recover the data because
it provides good speed low latency
recovering the data is going to be a lot
sooner the next product or service or
we're gonna discuss in networking is
azure DNS now Azure DNS allows us to
host domain name in Azure and these
domain names come with an exceptional
performance and availability now Azure
DNS is used to set up and manage DNS
zones and records for our domain name in
the cloud now this Azure DNS is a
service for DNS just like the name says
and it provides name resolution by using
azure's infrastructure and by using this
domain we can actually manage the DNS
our cells through the Azure portal with
the same credential imagine having a DNS
provider which does not even belong in
RIT imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the DNS environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the DNS
in the very same Azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this Azure DNS very much integrates with
other DNA service providers it uses a
Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft and Global
Network of name servers can kind of
ensures that our domain names are
resolved properly not only properly but
also are available most of the time all
right next in the list in networking
Services is virtual Network I'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
I'm sure you're gonna like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
Azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this then this Azure
virtual Network helps us to provision
Azure virtual machines and it helps us
to securely communicate with other
on-premises and internet networks it
also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or Flows In and Out
of This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments of
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's witness that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision our vpns in the cloud so we
can connect the cloud and the
on-premises infrastructure and lot more
especially in a environment where we
have hybrid environment surely we will
be using virtual Network because that's
going to require VPN for secure data
transfer in and out of the cloud and in
and out of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the Azure resources
the kind of logically stay in between or
logically stay within the Azure virtual
Network and here we can design the
network is given over to us you know you
can pick the IP you can pick the routing
you can pick the subnet and a lot of
freedom is given or I would say a lot of
control on how the network is designed
it's not like something that's already
cooked and we only get to use it no we
can actually build the network from the
scratch we can pick the IP address that
we like we can pick you know which
subnet needs to communicate with the
other subnets stuff like that and like I
said if you are using hybrid environment
you definitely would be requiring a
virtual Network because it helps connect
the on-premises and the cloud in a
secure fashion using VPN the last
product we're going to discuss and
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good Network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
cross premises virtual networks with
Azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the back end pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now Azure storage in general is
a Microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
Azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes Azure data Lake it
includes Azure files as you see it in it
includes Azure queues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
of storage to nearly 60 percent of how
much you would be actually spending
without using it so Azure simple storage
or store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on-premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around the hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with Azure especially when it comes
to storage a lot of the things that
we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in Azure
Data Center and this store simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage tiering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
use data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed to the cloud so you see
how this storage tiering automatically
happens in store simple and one another
cool feature of store simple is that it
enables us to create an on-demand and
scheduled backups of data and and then
store the data locally or in the cloud
and these backups are actually taken in
the form of of incremental snapshot
which means that they can be created and
restored quickly it's not a complete
backup it's an incremental backup and
these Cloud snapshots they can be
critically important when there is a
disaster and when there is a disaster
recovery scenario because these
snapshots can be called in and they can
be put on storage systems and then they
become the actual data so recovering is
faster if you have proper scheduled
backups or if you have frequent backups
and this storage simple it really helps
in easing our backup mechanism which
means it kind of eases our Disaster
Recovery steps or procedures as well so
the store simple it can be used to
automate data management data migration
data movement data tearing across the
Enterprise both in cloud and on-premises
it actually improves the compliance and
accelerates the disaster recovery for
our environment and if there is one
thing that's increasing every new day in
our environment that will be storage and
this stores simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much free
planning on storage is needed yes there
will be a need but not as much as I
would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data Lake store this data
Lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this is data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and other any injection speed and it
kind of collects them in one single
space or in one single place for
operational efficiency I mean
operational efficiency and for analytic
purpose Hadoop in Azure is very
dependent on this data Lake storage and
this data Lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using Hadoop in the cloud in
Azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or or the normal
procedure or the Right Storage to pick
would be data Lake store in Azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use Azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses Azure blob
storage behind the scenes for or global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for Azure
Cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
Azure blob storage is Microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for Rapid reads if I explain
to you on what scenarios we will be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many ID
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of Fetchers can fetch data
from Azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of Disaster
Recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud ID
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates an data a new version
gets created which means at any point I
can roll back as and when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable queues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workloads let's expand this
queue storage for a moment now this Q
storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through HTTP
and https calls a single queue or a
single Cube message can be up to like 24
KB in size and a single queue can
contain millions of such 24 KB in size
messages and how much can it hold it can
hold up to the total capacity of the
storage account account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate How much would
it hold and this Azure queue storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling in the application so you
know it's not very dependent or
sometimes it's not at all dependent on
the other application because now we
have a queue in between which kind of
translates or which kind of connects or
which kind of decouples both the
environment now we have a queue in
between both the environment can scale
up or scale down independently the next
in the storage service would be file
storage let's talk about file storage
now these Azure files provide secure
simple and managed Cloud file shares now
with file share in the cloud it actually
extends the user servers on-premises
performance and capacity and lot of
familiar tools for the cloud file share
management can be used along with the
file storage that we're talking about so
let's expand a bit on file storage now
this Azure files or Azure file storage
offers a fully managed file shares in
the cloud that can be accessed via the
SMB protocol server message block
protocol now this Azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible Linux is
compatible Mac OS is compatible in an
addition to all this being able to run
on on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on-premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
I would say that some Advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a nosql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one will end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of data it's a
lot cheaper when you compare it with the
traditional SQL data or data storage so
some of the things that we can store in
the table storage are are of course
they're going to be flexible data sheets
such as user data for web application
address books device information and
other types of metadata for our service
requirements and it can have any number
of tables up to the capacity limit of
the storage account now this is not
possible with SQL this is only possible
with nosql especially with table storage
in Azure explanation of storage really
concluded the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his ID
personal but this ID personal is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after this lengthy discussion and
his question was well there are a lot of
other Cloud providers available what
made you specifically choose Azure I
mean from the kind of question that he
asked we can say that he is very curious
and he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from a different angle
now so he started to explain what are
the capabilities or how Azure is better
than the competitor so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and I'm going to tell you
what the CEO told his ID person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by Microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is dotnet friendly
Azure supports the dotnet programming
language and it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and new applications deployed
using.net programming framework so if
your application is dot net most of the
time you would end up picking Azure I
mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking Azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that Azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development life cycle which is an
industry leading Assurance process when
we buy services from Azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like I mentioned many times in the past
and I would like to mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of the cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the documentation it's picture rich
and the documentations are neat and
clear with really it would encourage you
to learn more it will encourage you to
think and imagine and try easily get a
grasp of how Services work so it has a
very gentle learning curve Azure allows
the utilization of technologies that
several business have used for years so
there is a big history behind it it has
a very gentle learning curve the
certifications the documentations the
stage by stage certification levels it's
all very gentle learning curve which is
generally missing in other clouds
service providers now this would really
impress the ctOS or people working in
finance and budgeting if an organization
is already using Microsoft software they
can definitely go and Avail or be bold
and ask for a discount that can reduce
the overall Azure spending in other
words overall a pricing of the Azure so
that's what helped or they are the
information that helped the CEO pick
Azure as his cloud service provider and
then the CEO goes on and talks about the
different companies that are currently
using Azure and they are definitely
using Azure for a reason like Pixar
Boeing Samsung EasyJet Xerox BMW 3M they
are major multinational multi-billion
companies they rely run operate their ID
in Azure and this CEO has a thought that
his it person is still not very
convinced unless and until he shows him
a visual of how easy things are in Azure
so he goes on and explains about a
practical application of azure which is
what exactly I'm going to show you as
well all right a quick project on
building an Azure app using or building
a dotnet application in Azure web app
and making it connect to nsql database
will solidify all the knowledge that we
have gained so far so this is what we're
gonna do I have an Azure account open as
you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh right I'm logged in and this is
what we're going to do so we're going to
create an application like this which is
nothing but an to-do application a to-do
list application we're just going to run
from the web app get information from us
and save it in the database that's
connected to it so you can already see
it's a two-tier application web and DB
all right so let me go back to my Azure
account the first thing is to create an
Resource Group let's give it an a
meaningful name let's call it Azure
simply learn right and it's going to be
a free trial and the location pick one
that's nearest to you or you know
wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case I'm
going to pick Central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this example so
let's create an web app give it a quick
name let's call it azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and I'm
going to use my existing Resource Group
a resource Group that we created some
time back it's going to run out of
Windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running let me create my
database
right SQL database create a database
give it a name let's call it Azure
simply learn DB
put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some settings like the name of
the server and the admin login the
password that goes along and in which
location this is going to be created the
server name is going to be Azure simply
learn DB that's the server name and the
admin login can be what can be the admin
login name let's see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now Azure
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created all right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of or that's in
Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console we're gonna go back to
visual studio feed these inputs in the
visual studio so the code knows what the
database is the the credentials to log
into the database stuff like that so
we're going to feed those information in
Visual Studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while we really got to be patient right
now we have all the resources that we
need for the application to run here is
my database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is create and firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create a firewall exception rule right
so the application is going to run from
my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the database right so let's
add an exception rule by simply adding
the client type B it's going to pick my
IP the IP of the laptop I'm using as of
now and it's going to create an
exception to access the database so
that's done now we can go back to our
Visual Studio I already have a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from a visual
studio I'm going to clean that up if
you're doing it for the first time you
you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to how you would be
doing in your environment right so we're
going to select an existing Azure app
service now before that I have logged in
as you can see I have logged in with my
credentials so it's going to pull a few
things automatically from my Azure
account so in this case I'm gonna use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
all right we have clicked on Save and
it's running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an URL
now initially the URL is not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database that would
be the next thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my web app as of
now
it's gonna throw an error like you see
it's throwing another that's because we
haven't mapped the app and the DB
together so let's do that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server Explorer uh this is where we're
gonna see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource Group all right appropriate
to Service Group
which is right here
and here I have my database azure
simply learn database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application
right so let's go to the solution
Explorer click on publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my DB connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my DB now if you recall rdb was uh
Azure simply learn DB and that's not
being shown here so let's fix that
all right so let's fix that
click on configure and here let's put
our DB servers URL now before that let's
change this to SQL Server
all right and then in here I'll put the
DBS URL so go back to azure
here is my
DB or server's name
put that here
right
the username to connect to the server
that's right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
azure
portal or the Azure infrastructure and
here is my database if you recall it's
azure
sldb that's the name of the database
Let's test the connection
connection is good click on OK
so now it's showing up correctly Azure
simply learn DB that's the name of the
database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is azure simply learn DB
and then
it's going to be
SQL Server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn and the
password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate the connection
it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish our application
again now the application knows how to
connect to the database we have educated
it with the uh the correct connection
strings the DNS name the username and
the password for the application to
connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an URL to connect
and anytime we put or we give inputs to
the URL that's going to receive the
input and save it in the database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and I can start creating to-do list for
myself all right so I have the items
already listed I can create an entry and
these entries get stored in the in the
database I can create another entry
and I'll take the dog for a walk that's
gonna get stored I can create another
entry uh book tickets for a scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and I'll put
that in the database and that concludes
our session so through this session we
saw how I can use Azure services to
create web app and connect that to the
DB instance and how those two Services
which are decoupled by default which are
separate by default how I can you know
use the connection strings to make
connection between the app server and
the database and be able to create an
working app I strongly believe you
enjoyed me walking you through this
session so in this video here's what
we're going to talk about first we'll
talk about what is cloud computing what
is Microsoft Azure what are the services
that Azure offers and then we'll have a
look at a use case where we'll be
applying one of these services to get a
particular job done now for the first
question what is cloud computing so
cloud computing actually provides a
platform through which you can access
resources now these resources include
server storage app application security
and other ways you can transform your
data or get some use out of it now at
the same time you can also store manage
and process your data now anything
related to cloud computing is made
possible only with the help of the
internet now along with these things
there are several other things that you
can do with cloud computing now let's
have a look at some of the ways cloud
computing is making our lives better
firstly you have services for just about
every requirement that you have then you
get access to the newest and most
Innovative Technologies in the market
right now cloud computing provides
cost-effective Solutions with flexible
pricing now most cloud service providers
work in such a way that you only pay for
the amount of time you use that
particular resource then you have one of
the most important selling points when
it comes to cloud computing which is
that data and applications are
accessible from any part of the world as
long as you have access to the internet
and finally you have increased
protection for your data and
applications now you should know that
there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now be
Amazon web services Adobe Creative Cloud
Google Cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms is one
that's growing really really fast and
that is Microsoft Azure now let's ask
the question what is Microsoft Azure
Microsoft Azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build manage scale and deploy
applications by giving them access to
cloud services now these cloud services
range from creating virtual machines to
creating functions that run themselves
without having to worry about Hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet now here are some
things that you need to know about Azure
firstly it was launched on the 1st of
February 2010 it has data centers in
more than 42 regions across the world
they also say the 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions next
Azure is preferred by eighty percent of
the Fortune 500 companies which means
that the best of the best in the market
only choose to work with this job and
finally Azure is the second largest
cloud service provider in the market
right now let's talk about Azure
Services as I told you Azure provides
services for a wide range of domains now
let's have a look at some of these
domains there's Ai and machine learning
compute containers database identity
management tools networking Security
Storage and so much more now let's have
a look at some of the individual
services within these domains firstly
you have Azure virtual machines with
Azure virtual machines what you get is
the opportunity to create Windows or
Linux virtual machines now all of this
is possible in a matter of seconds with
a large amount of customization now
let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example what size of operating system do
you want how much size do you want
allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now Azure provides you per minute
billing which means that your only
charged for how much time you use the
service and finally you have enhanced
security and protection for your virtual
machines next we have service fabric now
with service fabric you have platform
which enables you to create micro
Services now this also makes the process
of application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
can create applications with a faster
time to Market it supports Windows Linux
on-premises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by Azure now let's have a
look at the networking Services firstly
we have the Azure CDN or the content
delivery network with Azure CDN what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
CDN can be integrated with several other
Azure services so that the process can
move at a faster rate it can handle
heavy loads and traffic spikes with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get Advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have express route with express route
you can connect your on-premises network
to Azure through a private Network Now
by default this lowest latency it
increases the emphasis on reliability
and speed and it can be of great use
when you have to transfer large amounts
of data between networks now another way
this can be useful is if it's used to
add compute or storage capacity to Data
Centers next we have Azure DNS domain
name service or Azure DNS can be used to
host your domains on Azure this provides
High availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to DNS
queries by taking advantage of
Microsoft's Global Network it also
provides High availability next we have
virtual Network Azure virtual Network
allows the Azure resources to
communicate with each other or other
on-premise networks via the Internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private Network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the Azure
Network and it also allows users to
design their own networks next we have
traffic manager now with traffic manager
you can route incoming traffic to
improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application runtime and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you have provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing High availability and
improved Network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have Azure VPN Gateway now this allows
users to connect their on-premise
networks to Azure using a side-to-site
VPN now this allows users to connect
their virtual machine to anywhere in the
world through a point to site VPN and
also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available now let's talk about
the storage Services first we have data
Lake storage now with this what you get
is a scalable data storage with an
emphasis on cost Effectiveness and
scalability now it comes with maximum
use when you integrate it with other
services so that you you can get
analytics on how the data is being used
it is also integrated with other
services like the Azure blob storage now
it is also optimized for Big Data
analysis tools like Apache spark and
Hadoop next up we have blob storage The
Blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data Integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data has
been accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have queue storage
now with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable
Q storage provides queue monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer's
demands are met then we have files
stored now with file storage you can
perform file sharing with the help of
the SMB protocol or the server message
block protocol now this data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and the https
protocol in this case like we mentioned
in functions Azure takes care of all the
hardware needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on-premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
end prices next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services first we
have the Azure search now with Azure
search you get a cloud search service
which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web application as well as mobile
applications now one big Advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices Azure takes care of
that and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search as structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
Solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software as a service
applications and Enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales Up and Down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows next let's have
a look at some container services first
let's talk about ACS or Azure container
services it is also known as the Azure
kubernetes Services as it's a fully
managed kubernetes container
orchestration service now what this
means is that it eases the process of
container integration and deployment it
also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database Services first we
have the SQL database now with SQL
database what you get is a relational
cloud data a service now this means that
it helps accelerate your app development
and makes it easier for you to maintain
your application now SQL database is
also used extensively in migrating
workloads to the cloud and hence saves
time and cost it also helps improve your
performance by integrating machine
learning and Adaptive Technologies into
your database next we have Azure Cosmos
DB now this is a globally distributed
multi-model database service now what
this means is that with this you can
create application with support nosql it
provides a high grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and highly
unpredictable workload now let's have a
look at some security and identity
Services firstly we have the Azure
active directory now if you want to know
more about Azure active directory I
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the Azure
active directory this is just an intro
production so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to Advanced threats in
real time next you have Azure active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what Azure adb2c
does now it also enables the application
to be scaled to great amounts even
billions of customers next we have the
Azure security Center this is basically
like a command post with which you get a
complete view of the security across
users on your on-premises and Cloud
workloads so with this you are given
threat protection method that adapts to
situations and helps reduce exposing you
to threats it also has rapid threat
response and makes the process of
finding and fixing vulnerabilities a
whole lot easier next up let's talk
about monitoring and Management Services
so first let's have a look at as your
advisor now Azure advisor is basically a
guide for the best practices when it
comes to Azure now when you follow these
it improves performance security cost
and increases availability now it also
learns from how you use the services on
your configuration and usage pattern and
the adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have Network Watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to login to your virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming toward you how much you're giving
and so much more it also helps diagnose
VPN problems that you might have with
detailed logs and finally you have the
Azure resource manager now with this you
can ensure that the resources that you
have are managed and deployed at a
consistent rate now this makes it
extremely easy for you to manage and
visualize your resources that are used
in your applications or some other
requirements and you can control who can
access your resources as well as perform
actions on it and now let's have a look
at how we can use one of these services
to satisfy a particular requirement so
the friend asks that she needs one last
bit of help she wants a friend's help to
host the website on Azure and here's how
we can do it so now we're going to put
one of these Services into action
machine learning's major purpose is to
train models and anticipate outcomes
that may be used by applications
scripts are used in Azure machine
learning to train models using machine
learning Frameworks that enable us to
quickly operationalize diverse machine
learning jobs and iterative processes
while leveraging Microsoft azure's
massive computational power
but knowing this much is not enough and
therefore here we are
so hello everyone welcome to this new
video of Simply learn on Azure machine
learning
in this video we'll go through Azure
machine learning in detail including its
capabilities the Azure ecosystem that
supports machine learning and the
various ways we train and build models
starting with
what is azure machine learning followed
by who is machine learning for
then we will look into its
infrastructure Readiness and security
then we will dive into machine learning
project workflow
following that we will understand
mlops devops for machine learning and at
last we will explore the Azure machine
Learning Studio
after that we will have a demo too
so without doing any further dealing
let's start with the video
so what is azure machine learning
Azure machine learning is a Cloud
solution that helps you speed up and
manage your machine learning projects it
can be used by Machine learning
Specialists data scientists and
engineers in the daily workflows models
are trained and deployed and mlops are
managed
you can use an open source platform like
pytorch tensorflow or scikit-learn to
build a model or use one created in
Azure machine learning
model monitoring retraining and
redeployment are all made easier using
these tools
but this brings us to a question
that who exactly machine learning is for
so individuals and teams deploying mlops
inside their company can use Azure
machine learning to move machine
learning models into production it is
safe and auditable environment
data scientists and machine learning
experts will find tools to help them
speed up and automate their daily tasks
tools for embedding models into
applications or services will be
available to application Developers
platform developers will find a strong
set of tools for constructing Advanced
ml technology underpinned by resilient
agile resource manager apis
now that we know the basics of azure ml
let's have a look at its infrastructure
Readiness and security
so Azure machine learning is an Azure
Cloud platform that adds security
to machine learning projects
so Integrations for security include the
following network security groups in
Azure virtual Networks Azure keyboard is
a world where you may store security
Secrets like storage account access
details
and set up an Azure container registry
behind the v-net
so now let's dive down deep and explore
its project workflow
models are usually created as part of
project with a specific goal and
objective multiple people are usually
involved in these projects iterative
development is used while experimenting
with data algorithms and models
now coming to the Project Life Cycle
while the project lifespan will differ
depending on the project it will
typically look like this
a workspace space organizes a project
and facilitate collaboration among
multiple users who are all working
toward the same goal
users in a workspace May easily share
the result of the experiments through
the studio user interface or they can
use versioned assets for jobs like
environments and storage references
so users work can be automated in a
machine learning Pipeline and activated
on a timetable or https request when a
project is ready for operation therefore
models can be deployed to the manage
interferencing solution in real time or
batch abstracting away the
infrastructure management that is
traditionally necessary for model
deployment
now let's proceed further and understand
the concept of mlops that is devops for
machine learning
mlops or devops for machine learning is
a process for generating models for
production use
if not reproducible the lifetime of a
model from training to deployment must
be auditable
mlops or machine learning operations is
based on devops principles and methods
to improve workflow efficiency
continuous integration delivery and
deployment for example these ideas are
applied to the machine learning process
by mlops with the purpose of
experimentation and model deployment can
be done more quickly and quality
assurance and end-to-end lineage
tracking are more efficient ways to put
models into production
now
let's explore what is azure ml Studio
so Azure machine Learning Studio is an
online service that includes low code
and no code alternators for project
development and asset management in
Azure machine learning
basically it is a workspace where you
can create build train the machine
learning models
for inclusive data science platform the
studio integrates no code and no code
first experience
so now that we have covered all the
important concepts of azure machine
learning
let's have a demo for a better
understanding of how machine learning is
used in azure
so let's start with the Demo First you
need to browse the Link studio dot Azure
ml.net and here you need to log in with
your Azure account
so once you have logged in you will be
led to a new window
this is new window here you can see a
few options
so let's start and see one by one what
these options are
so the first one is projects
basically this gives you a list of all
the experiments that you have already
worked on so here you can see we haven't
worked on any experiment yet
then comes experiment
experiments are all the programs and
codes that you have worked on to create
it or deploy a model that you've just
created for an experiment
so as I said we haven't created any
experiment yet so the list is and I'll
over here
when you click on samples you can see a
few
sample experiments provided to you by
azure
portal by default
and following that we have web services
so we all know since Azure is a cloud
computing platform so all the data
gathered from my experiments needs to be
uploaded to the cloud so web services
gives you a list of all the experiments
that you have in the cloud so you can
access them from anywhere
so when you create an experiment and
work on it when you add it to the cloud
that data is stored here
so then comes data sets
it gives you all the data sets you have
in your Azure portal when you click on
the samples option
again you can see all this data sets
provided to you by default in your hash
shop portal
then comes train models
so while working on an experiment you
will come across a point where you need
to train your model
so basically this gives you a list of
all the models that you have trained in
your experiments or Azure programs
okay
and in the last com settings
any changes that you want to make to
your workspace is done under settings
here you can see uh this is your
workspace name workspace description
which is by default
and all the details is provided
here only so whatever changes you want
to make your workspace you will be doing
this over here
so now let's start with a demo
so down below you can see the ad or new
Option here
so click on it
and then you can see there are a few
ways uh templates provided by you
provided to you by Azure itself so we'll
click on blank experiment
once you click on the blank experiments
uh you'll be guided to a new experiment
window
so this is the new window and this
window is divided into three parts
these are the components
where you will plan your model
this is the canvas to design your model
and then the properties of the model
in the components section you can see
samples already present there so you can
select any one of them according to your
requirement so here when I'm typing
samples
uh
I'll work on airport codes data sets so
I just need to drag this option over
here
but before starting uh with our
experiment let's change the name
so here I'm changing it to airport
codes
demo model
so now you can see the name of the
experiment is changed
now when you click on it
and select visualize
the second
you can see the number of rows and
columns provided to it the datas which
is required for its data set to be
created and for its model to be created
so the four rows four columns are
airport ID city state and name
now we will move towards the part where
we Define field we need to make a
predictions for so type columns in the
search
bar
uh under manipulation section
you can see there are multiple options
provided to you
so here we will select
select columns and data sets
as we are working on data sets
now connect your data set with this
option
so you can see a red alert over here so
when you click on it
you can see it is asking for values in
your data set so to add values click on
the launch column selector under
properties
section
so once you click on it here you need to
select all the options needed per
required values so for my experiment
model I need all these data sets so I'll
add all of these and then click on the
save option
so let me just add this
all the values I need in our in my data
set
so now you can see the alert is gone
so now we have the data sets that we
want to work on so let's look for an
appropriate algorithm for it
so while looking into the classification
algorithm
we know that our
so here you can see it under
classification model we have these
options
so we know that our Target value is
divided into two classifications so the
algorithm we will be using is a
two class
so we will be using two class booster
dissection tree
because it calculates the accuracy for
every node and once the calculated
accuracy is more than a required
accuracy then only it moves to the next
node
so basically this gives you a prediction
value close to the accurate value of the
model
we will just drag this option over here
so now the next step we have is to train
our model
so we just need to type train over here
and select train model option
so
just drag it to the canvas now connect
the two booster decision tree to the
train model
now you can again see the red a lot for
a required data as it doesn't have any
data to work on so our next step is to
split the data
so we'll type split
and drag the split data option on our
canvas
as you can see this is also saying
it needs an input Port data set so we'll
connect our data set with it
so
that it is provided with the
data
so when you click on it you can see it
it is asking for a split percentage
so you split the data into training and
testing where 80 goes to training and 20
to testing so we will mention 0.08 over
here
and
so now we will just connect the 80 data
off to the train model
as we said the 80 goes for training
but you can still see the alert in the
train model because it is not aware of
the column
it needs to train on
so we will click on
uh
launch column selector
now you just need to select all the
columns
you need to work on so I'm selecting the
airport ID number
now you can see uh once I save it
the other alert is gone
now our next step is to find the score
of a model so let's type score
in our search bar
and drag the score model over
here
let me just reduce the size of the
canvas yeah
so we will just connect our train model
to the score model
so
again you will see the Red Alert as it
doesn't know the data it needs to test
on so for that we will connect the
remaining testing data in the split data
option to the
score model
now you can see the alert option is gone
now coming to the final step that is
evaluation of the model so let's type
evaluation
and here you can see the evaluate model
option we just need to drag it to the
canvas
so
let's
connect it with our score model
now your model for the app port code
data set is complete so this is the
whole
model
now you need to save the model and then
click on run option
so here I've saved it
and you can see it's running
you can see the model running and going
through every node
as you can see the green mark
as it's verifying through every node
so once it's done click on evaluate
model
and then click on visualize
now you can see the accuracy is a
yo you can see the accuracy is 98 which
is almost the prediction value now you
can see the positive and negative labels
as well
so this whole data is known as confusion
Matrix
now for the values close to the pos
positive label it gives me the number of
true predictions
that uh the number of data I'll provide
it will it shows that 72 predictions
will be right and one will be wrong
now let's go back and
run this model over the web
so by clicking on a setup web service we
will click on predictive web service
now we will just connect web service
input to the score model
so that once the program is uploaded to
the cloud it is directly connected to
the score model
and gives us the output
so now you need to save this
and run
this will execute the entire model now
all uh we are
left with is deploying the model
now
you just need to click on deploy web
service
so then you will see you will be taken
to a new window
here you can see the response page where
it's showing test option you need to
click on it
so here you can see a new window has
popped up so you just need to mention
the details like for City I am
mentioning Bangalore
foreign
and name of the airport is
International
Airport
and I just need to save this data
so now down below you can see it gives
me predictive values
and this is the airport ID
for my mention details so the accuracy
of this ID will be 0.98 which is 98
percent
which is almost accurate to the hundred
so this was our experiment and this is
how we can use ml in Azure hey everyone
I'm shamli and I welcome you all to this
new video of Simply learn on Azure
active directory
in this video I will take you through
what is azure active directory
followed by what is the difference
between Windows 80 and Azure ad then we
will look into the services audience I.E
who uses these services
and at last we will have a quick demo of
azure active directory
so let's get started with the video
first what is azure active directory
but before getting into the definition
of azure ad let's have a real life
example of azure ID to understand it in
a better way
there are a lot of pre-created
applications that you can offer user
access to using Azure ad
so Netflix is one of them so here's the
scenario
you want to share a Netflix account with
a dozen people from your organization
giving your Netflix username and
password to everyone isn't safe
so how do you give them access
your end does Azure ad
the Netflix application is available in
the Azure ad gallery and can be added to
your Azure ad tenant
this adds the application to your
tenancy and allows you to save your
Netflix credentials in the secured
credentials store so that users can be
assigned to it
the only people who have access are the
ones you give it to unless they have
their own account you're essentially
building a company wide password Vault
then assigning people to the systems
they require access to so they can log
in without knowing the username and
password for those systems so all they
need is the Azure 80 account or password
and Azure ID will handle the rest
so saying in technical terms Azure
active directory is a cloud-based
identity and access management
service from Microsoft that allows your
employees to sign in and access
resources such as Microsoft 365 the
Azure portal and thousands of other SAS
apps
and internal resources such as apps on
your company's intranet and network as
well as any Cloud apps built by a
company
Azure ad is required for sign-in and
identity protection in Microsoft online
business services such as Microsoft 365
and azure
if you sign up for any Microsoft online
business
you will be given access to Azure 80
which includes all of the free services
but what makes Azure ads different from
Windows 80 that it has become more
popular among people from technical firm
what is Windows 80
active directory saves information about
Network objects and make it easier for
administrator and users to find and use
their information
it organizes directory information
logically and hierarchically using a
structured data store
but it's Supreme drawback is its layers
so let's have a look at its list and its
functioning
first is adds Windows active directory
domain services
active directory domain Services is an
example of a directory service that
provides mechanisms for storing
directory data and making it available
to network users and administrators
second is adfs active directory
Federation services
Federated identity and access management
is made possible by active directory
Federation service
with securely shares digital identity
and entitlements right across security
and corporate boundaries to provide
customers partners and suppliers with a
streamlined user experience while
accessing an organization's web-based
applications
adfs extends the ability to employ
single sign-on capability accessible
within a single security or Enterprise
boundary to internet facing apps
third is
adrms active directory right Management
Services
Microsoft's active directory Rights
Management Services safeguards sensitive
documents and emails unlike traditional
security methods like firewalls and ACLS
adrms encryption and protection remain
constant regardless of where a file goes
or how it is transferred
but Azure active directory actually
combine these layers and make the whole
process more easier and hassle-free
Azure Ed combines these layers into two
layers waad Windows Active Azure
directory and windows Azure Access
Control service
Windows Active Azure directory combines
all the problems revolving around
identification management
and windows Azure Access Control service
takes care of federating all the
services of an organization
so let's have an example when an
employee joined the premises of an
organization the administrator guides
them towards signing to particular
Services they use and then give access
to it and the employees can access these
Services through their credentials like
username and password
now that we know what is azure active
directory and how it functions different
from adds let's have a look at the
service audience of azure active
directory
Azure ad is majorly intended to RIT
admins app developers and online
subscribers
for it admins you can use Azure ad as an
IT administrator to limit access to your
apps and app resources based on your
business needs when accessing critical
organizational resources for example you
can utilize Azure 80 to enforce
multi-factor Authentication
finally Azure active directly provides
you with strong features to help you
protect users identities and credentials
while also meeting your access
governance requirements as an app
developer you may utilize Azure ad to
add single sign-on to your app using a
standard based method allowing it to
function with the user's existing
credentials
also Azure ad
has apis that may be used to create
customized app experiences based on
existing organizational data
for online subscribers
you're already using Azure area as a
subscriber
each tenant of Microsoft 365 Office 365
Azure and dynamic CRM online is an Azure
ad tenant by default
you may begin managing access to your
connected clouds apps right away
so now that we know the basic concept of
azure any let's have a quick demo of it
so the first thing we need to do is
login in our Azure ID account
and then go to Azure active directory
sector
here you will see add option where you
can add a user group Enterprise
application app registration according
to your choice
and below that
you can search for any tenant like the
user
or for any group
so right now it doesn't belongs to any
group or there is no user
with this name
here you will get basic information like
their name what is the ID what is the
license
which groups they belong
and whatever devices they use you can
also have an access to their password as
well now why should you be interested in
data Factory now let's consider a
scenario so here we have two colleagues
having a conversation with each other
and they say that the data that they're
generating from their applications of
products is increasing exponentially now
considering that this data is coming
from a number of different products
it'll be a bit of a task to analyze and
store all of this data so he wonders how
they're going to manage that his friend
suggests that they use azure's data
Factory now what does azure's data
Factory actually do first it stores data
with the help of the data Lake storage
now any kind of data can be stored in
the data Lake storage then you can
analyze the data you can transform the
data with the help of pipelines and you
can publish the organized data you can
visualize the data with third-party
applications like Apache spark or Hadoop
as well now what exactly is data Factory
so now let's have a look at what exactly
is data Factory now data Factory falls
under of the identity domain of services
in the Azure catalog and is a
cloud-based integration service
basically what it does is it works on
your data it stores your data it
orchestrates and automates the movement
or transformation of data it works
heavily on the data that you store now
let's see how it actually works or how
the flow of its processes are firstly we
have the input data set which is nothing
but the data that you have within your
data store the one that you need
processed then you pass this data
through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it it could be anything from
just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures or high now after this
is done you get an output data set now
this output data set will contain data
that is in a structured form because
it's already been transformed and made
structured in the pipeline stage then it
is given into Link services like as your
data Lake block storage or SQL now what
it does is restore information that is
very important when it comes to
connecting to an external Source now
this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an SQL Server
you need to mention the source and
destination of your data now for example
consider an SQL Server so you need a
connection string so that you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
Link services work and finally you need
a Gateway now a Gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the Azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like Apache spark R
Hadoop and so on so all this time I've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to Azure
data Factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
Lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
Frameworks which is external Frameworks
like Hadoop Apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the Azure
data Lake store and then it is provided
two external Frameworks like R Apache
and Spark so that they can be worked on
now there are two main Concepts when it
comes to data Lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here here
are two examples of how analytics works
when it comes to data Lake now when it
comes to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the current the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the Azure data Factory
to move data from an SQL database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on Google it's called you just need
to Google it ssms the first thing you
can take here there you have it so you
just need to click here and download the
file so we I've already downloaded the
file so basically this is used to create
a database which will be transferring to
The Blob storage so this will take about
depending on your computer speed pretty
long or little to no time I've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes and
finally once the installation is done
here's what we're going to do we should
go into the dashboard of Microsoft this
year we need to create a data warehouse
so we'll go into all the sources Creator
Source go to database
and select SQL data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so I've already set
up a possible set of names
YouTube
it's free trial the source is already
created
a blank database the server we need to
create a new one so let me read me that
we'll name it as YouTube server
YouTube
admin as the server admin login
the password as
right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done and here we need to change how much
you want the lowest I mean how much
computation you want how much did
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and create
so now we're creating an SQL data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and go to the resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which I've already opened here and then
go here
and copy this paste it here as your
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is admin
YouTube admin and the password which is
also given there
go to options we go to the database name
which is YouTube
everything else is there we need to
change it to TCP
and connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
again we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier we've got a databases
and here you have the YouTube database
that we just created right click this
and add a new query
I already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name Clark Kent last name is Bruce
Wayne and the table that's created will
have these two rows so now we're going
to execute this there you have it two
rows have been affected so now let's
have a look at our table
um
secure this line
and there you go the tables here so now
that this is done we're going back into
azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the storage
where the blob storage is going to
happen so we're going to storage
accounts and click on ADD so here it's a
free trial Resource Group is YouTube
storage account name is
okay us performance is standard
general purpose
you can do locally since we don't need
to be very reliable at least for this
one Advance just fine view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
which does not exist and okay
it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data Factory now so we go to all
services and search for data Factory
you press add
so here we'll
free trial use existing which we have
YouTube ecos and create so now we've
created a new data Factory
now we'll wait while it's been deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
we'll name it
uh description and once now
and now okay
right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so so what you
need to do is select a secure as your
SQL data warehouse so once again I go to
previous here we select Azure SQL data
warehouse go here
search for
source
media subscription free trial hey
YouTube server and the databases YouTube
you also need to provide your username
and password I've saved it here
YouTube admin
[Music]
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab next
next and now for our destination so
where are we going to connect this to
we're going to Azure blob storage next
destination
subscription free trial and simply store
now we need to name our
name our storage path next although this
can be
passed on
so here's what we're doing be it copying
whatever is inside this to the Azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the here's the visual
representation of what's Happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
now let's have a look if it's actually
worked out go to our database we'll go
into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
we've created a new one
and there you have it so based on the
container that you've named there it's
created a new one here so actually I
earlier created the name called simply
blob but as you can see here as long as
you name a container it'll create a
folder inside which you will find your
particular thing that you copied and
that's it you've copied data similarly
you can do a number of multiple
operations on this container on the on
the pipeline you just created with the
data Factory and that's that today we
are going to learn about the Azure
virtual machine so without further Ado
let's get started before getting in
depth let me tell you what's in store
for today first I'll be talking a little
about Azure next I'll start off by
explaining the Azure virtual machine
then I'll be focusing on few benefits of
azure watching machine moving forward
I'll be going in depth with the Azure
watching machine components and finally
we will be looking into a demo on Azure
virtual machine all of us may have heard
of azure at one point of time but what
is azure let me explain
azio is a cloud service created by
Microsoft for building testing and
managing applications and many services
through the Microsoft data centers the
Azure host web applications over the
Internet with the help of these data
centers
azio is very flexible it gives an option
to have the functionality as required
you can pay as you consume switch to
Azure and accommodate the business
fluctuations there's no need to worry
about the infrastructure all the time
Azure is very reliable and has 24 7 tech
support
Azure offers pay as you go pricing and
hence it is very cost effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust as your
supports backup and Disaster Recovery
tools
now we know what Azure is and its key
benefits let's now move on to Azure
watching machine before that let's
consider a scenario
Rachel had to host 10 virtual machines
at once per project there was an issue
when her computer RAM was not compatible
with the instances
the computer RAM was only 8 GB and the
instances that required were 10 GB then
she says I wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra RAM memory one of a colleague
heard this and he comes up with an idea
he says can we use Azure virtual machine
it has a pay as you go pricing and has
this for storage
you can pay for what you use and create
any number of instances with high
storage capacity also if any technical
difficulty arises you can easily
retrieve the files through the backup
server so now she's happy and she wants
to know more about Azure washing machine
Azure watching machine is one of the
wide range of services that Azure offers
to create your instance a virtual
machine is a computer file typically
called an image which behaves like an
actual computer it runs in a window
giving the user the same experience on a
virtual machine as they have on the host
operating system itself multiple
watching machines can run simultaneously
on the same physical computer each
virtual machine provides its own
Hardware like CPUs memories and other
devices as your virtual machine offers a
high range of flexibility and it
maintains the physical Hardware that
runs on it let me explain some of the
benefits of azure watching machine first
we have easy development and test as
your virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application next agility and scale Azure
virtual machine is agile and the ability
to clone and spin up multiple instances
of the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services and applications rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively as
your virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost as
your virtual machines provide extended
Data Center and can be easily connected
to an organization's Network it is easy
to set up your redundant infrastructure
in Azure and Azure provides a full
Disaster Recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore let me explain
Azure virtual machine components in
details virtual machine comes under the
compute domain of azure it also offers
various services like availability sets
snapshots disks images and many other
services like hosts virtual machine can
be clubbed with other services like disk
images availability sets hosts and many
more so the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like Ubuntu Red Hat
Linux Windows Server sent OS you can
also set the operating disk size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is disks as your original
machine use attached virtual hard disks
for storage take two types of virtual
hard disks first is an image it is a
template for creation of new Azure
virtual machine then we have disks it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
discs are backed up by Page blocks in
Azure storage therefore the disks
inherit the benefits of block storage
High availability durability and many
more the discs are mounted as drives on
the VM the next component is virtual
Network many components operate the
virtual machines in a scalable and
secure manner virtual networks could
include equipment such as separate
Network spaces for internet facing and
back-end servers load balancers
firewalls and more many of these
components are deployed into an Azure
virtual Network as your virtual Network
provides many features such as subnet IP
address load balancer and Network
Security Group another important
component of azure virtual machine is
availability sets if in case there's a
slight chance there could be a failure
in physical servers then these come into
picture so in case of such failure the
Azure platform will migrate the failed
virtual machine to a healthy host to
reconstitute the VM it is highly
recommended to deploy at least two
instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what Azure virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this Demo First we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into Microsoft Azure with your
credentials now let's click on Virtual
machines and create a new one
so I can put add
and you can use the subscription you
want either pay as you go pricing or
free tile
Resource Group will create a new one
that is pre-roll
one
okay virtual machine we can create I'm
going to use VM web
and then region I'll be using Okay East
US
then image I'll be using Windows Server
R2 Data Center
size I'll be using B1 MS
select
username and name
and then password of your choice
and then I'm gonna allow selected ports
and choose rdb3389
and next
so OS test step I'll be using standard
HD
and then yeah next
so I can see a default virtual Network
and it default submit in public IP as
well as default
then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
I'm going to select an extension to
install and I'm going to install
Microsoft anti-malware
create okay
I'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so I've created Five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
watching machine and see our virtual
machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the IP address
then hit Windows plus r
and open mstsc
and
paste the IP address and connect
let's use a different account
you have to use the administrator
account that we created before with the
same password
click ok
another remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next
select role bees or feature based
installation and click on next
then select the virtual machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server IIs next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close this
and open Internet Explorer
let's type in
http
localhost
yeah so now we can see the default was
opening let's minimize this
and let's try it here
we have to just put the IP address
I think there's an issue
okay so let's add an import Port
networking select networking and add in
one port
that's number 480
and add
okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh it
now we can see the default web brows
opening so the next step is to modify
the web browser let's go ahead with that
go back to your remote session host
thank you
let's go file explorer
so certain folders are created from the
C drive let's open that
it would be under kind of Pub
okay so this is where the default
process is coming from now let's make a
new text document
open that and put
foreign
[Music]
dot HD sorry
Mel
so this is a text document so we need to
change that
okay let's remove this
okay
let's start
now let's go back to our Internet
Explorer and hit F5
let's refresh this
let's try
so yeah so it's done now let's go back
to the previous browser and try let's
refresh
yeah that's done
hi guys a very warm welcome so today's
uh topic is azure virtual Network
tutorial
let's look into what's in it for you so
we would be covering why is azure
virtual Network important
what is azure virtual network is
benefits of using the Azure virtual
Network
components of our show virtual Network
that includes the subnet routing Network
Security Group why these components are
required to be created in the virtual
Network and how to launch an instance
within the Azure v-net or the virtual
Network and then we will be seeing one
demo in which we'll create Azure virtual
Network subnets and network security
groups so first of all let's look into
why is azure virtual Network important
so why Azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity time
consuming process and building Network
topologies could not divert Network
traffic to its destination on time so
these were a couple of challenges the
company was facing so the employees
thought that what could be the possible
solution to these challenges
and then we require the Azure virtual
Network in that case so first of all
let's understand what is azure virtual
network is and Azure v-net or a virtual
Network represents your network or
environment to run VMS and applications
in the cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
Internet so virtual Network you can
consider it as a virtual Cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud space
virtually assigned to the users or or to
the organization which they can
dedicatedly use for their purpose so for
example if you have to create some
instances or virtual machines onto the
Azure cloud
and you want to connect it with the
on-prem servers for example then you
might require the virtual Network in
that case let's assume that those
instances that are created in the
virtual Network require the range of IP
addresses that you want to allocate to
them and that is something you can
customize using the Azure virtual
Network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed to your instances in the
virtual Network how the firewall
Securities should be applied everything
the end user can control in the virtual
Network so it seems like that you are
working in your own data center ideally
you would be working on to the Azure
Cloud using the virtual Network
now what are the advantages of using the
Azure virtual Network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as I said that
it feels like it seems like that you are
working in your on-prem environment that
means within your data center but
ideally it is a virtual space that is
allocated to you which is a kind of an
isolated environment and that is
specifically designed for your tasks and
the activities
are generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
Network which can access the public
internet so there is a public network
connectivity that is enabled in the
virtual net so that a subnet which will
be created in the v-net can be accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control lists defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented High network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the Azure
Network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity it builds
sophisticated Network topologies in a
simple Manner and which is easily
manageable as well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual Network
one of them is the subnets
then you have routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the major or a
prime important component in the virtual
Network so what you have to do is first
obviously you would be creating a
virtual Network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning or virtual partitioning
inside the
virtual Network
subnet lets users segment the virtual
Network into one or more sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every Department there
should be some set of IP addresses that
you want to allocate to the machines
that the employees are using or all the
department should be isolated that means
that they should have their own network
IDs and the network addresses allocated
to their machines and in that case what
you would do is you would create the
subnets and the subnet IDs that would be
allocated to those departments these sub
networks can be separated logically and
each subnet consists of a server so what
you do is when you create a subnet you
can you can create a server or an
instance inside that subnet and how do
you want to give an access to that
instance depends on criteria or the
requirement hence a subnet can further
be divided into two parts one as the
public subnet and the other one as the
private subnet these are the naming
conventions of the subnet then how do
you want to give the internet
connectivity depends on how the public
subnet should be interacting with the
internet and for the private subnet as
the name suggests that the internet is
blocked so that means it is completely
isolated in the virtual Network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the NAT gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggests public instances that public
subnets that means they have the direct
internet connectivity next component is
routing and the routing is primarily a
routing rules you can say that are
applied and those are actually applied
to the routers only so since on the
cloud we cannot have a direct router
access and hence using the routing as a
component we can Define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router in the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet Azure virtual Network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
Network automatically a route table is
created and that basically is required
to Route the traffic and that can be
used by every subnet that doesn't mean
that you only have to create a single
route table in the virtual Network you
can have multiple route tables also
created which can be associated with
different subnets as well then you have
the network security groups it is kind
of a firewall that protects the virtual
machine by limiting the network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
Network traffic depending upon the
destination IP address port
and the protocol so it is basically the
network security group sits on the
instances and or virtual machines and
they basically Define that how the
traffic should be reaching to the ports
onto the virtual machine so how do you
want to open up the ports and for which
IP addresses you want to open up the
ports that is something the end user or
the administrator has to specify our
design so they act as a kind of a
firewall rules only that protects the
virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
v-net so first of all you have to create
a virtual Network so virtual Network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual Network then you would be
creating subnets which are considered as
a subset within the virtual Network
so Cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first v-nets are created then
the subnets are created and then you
configure the properties in the security
group
have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual Network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual Network in the Azure
cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual Network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual Network so you can
create one as a public subnet the other
one has a private subnet for example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual Network
for which virtual Network you're
creating an instance within that virtual
Network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created and then connect instance to a
relevant network security group so
attach your network security group to
the instances and based on the
properties or the rules that are defined
in the network security group that will
be applied to the instances within the
subnets finally configure the properties
in the network security and set the
policies as a result you will be able to
launch your instance on Azure within the
virtual Network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create Azure virtual Network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there uh to watch our demo on
the Azure virtual Network in today's
session I would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on Microsoft Azure and here you can see
on my screen that I have already logged
in into the Azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual Network you can type and
search in the dashboard in the search
bar with respect to the virtual Networks
and here you can find
the virtual Network and the gateways so
what you need to do is you just have to
click on the virtual networks and then
it will give you the options to add the
components inside the virtual Networks
so let me first open up the virtual
Network
right now in theory we discussed that
the virtual network comprises of
multiple components and sub components
so primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual Network then you have
to assign the ipv for cidr Block to the
virtual Network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual Network along with that you
define the routing rules and likewise
you create the instances inside the
subnets that will be part of the virtual
Networks
so that's what we are going to do in
this demo so I would be adding up a new
virtual Network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
v-net which is by default so when you
created the Azure credentials the demo
virtual network was already created by
the Azure so that it can provide you the
default settings and then the test one
has been created by me and that's the
customized one or you can say a
non-default virtual Network
so I'll I'm going to add another v-net
and
would Define
the name to it so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual Network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
Group so what is the resource Group it
is primarily a collection of resources
that share the same lifecycle
permissions and the policies so if you
have a resource Group uh created you can
use it otherwise you can create a new
Resource Group so I already have one
that is the demo one I would be using
that in the instance details you have to
specif the name of the virtual Network
so these are certain
uh parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say I
put something like test v-net
as the virtual Network that I want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created so these are the available
regions that you can select I would go
with us East
us only and then we have to define the
IP addresses also
see so in the IP addresses uh these cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed IP
address for that v-net so what you can
do is you can specify a range of IP
addresses now whenever we talk about a
virtual Network and the IP addresses we
primarily focus on the private IPS only
so this is the private IP that we are
actually talking about so I can reserve
some IP address cidr for our v-net and
that is the range of
40.0.0.0 16. I'm going to reserve so now
we'll create one subnet and we'll name
that subnet so as we discussed that
subnets are the sub components of the
v-net so here you can see we have
already created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and let's name it to something like demo
subnet right and the subnet should have
the IP address range and that IP address
range should be part of the v-net owned
in vtn so same subnet address range you
would be defining in the subnet as well
so that will be 40.0.1 dot or we can
select 2.0
slash 24.
the rest of the things would be default
we are not attaching any route table as
of now so just click on OK and here you
can see
that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we'll go
to the search bar and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test v-net
and inside the demo subnet so that our
virtual machine gets the private IP
address from the subnet that has been
created in the v-net itself so what you
need to do is you have to open up the
virtual machines click on ADD
and here you should add a new virtual
machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and the network details
where we would be defining the v-net as
well as the subnet where the virtual
machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource Group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name uh something like uh test VM
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking we would be
selecting
the test we net as our virtual Network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet so that is the recently
one added in the test we net and we want
that our virtual machine should be part
of that subnet only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public IP also
assigned since uh from the public
network we need to access those virtual
machines so we'll keep it enabled right
and the next uh would be the default
settings that we are going to proceed
with
so let's review all the configurations
and then
create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
v-net and it gets the private IP address
from the subnet that has been part of
the v-net which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine so let's
wait for a couple of more minutes and
we'll look into the status of the main
now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that our virtual
machine is created in a correct subnet
or not and that is something which we
can validate by checking the private IP
address so it got the private IP from
the range of the IP address that we have
specified in the subnet
now in order to access this particular
virtual machine you have to use the
public IP since uh since we have to
access it from the internet so from the
private IP this virtual machine will not
be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public IP address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
uh the virtual Network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other and that
actually creates a kind of an isolated
environment on the public Cloud which
gives you the understanding that you can
work into uh just like in on-prem
environment today we will discuss what
should an individual learn in the year
2021 so without further Ado let's get
started hello everyone welcome to an
amazing video of Simply learn on Azure
devops this video will help you
understand the use of devops in Azure as
well as it will help you explore the
in-depth services and features provided
to you by Azure devops so without doing
any further Ado let's start with the
video but before moving ahead please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon for more updates from
Simply learn
so let's see what we are going to cover
in this video
first we will understand what is azure
devops
followed by features of azure devops
then we will dive into and explore Azure
devops Services followed by Azure devops
server and then we will look into the
Azure devops services and Azure devops
server differences and at last we will
explore Azure devops Labs with proper
demonstration
so let's get started
so what is azure devops Azure devops
enables teams to organize work
collaborate on code development and
build and deploy applications using
developer Services Azure devops the
culture and set of protocols that brings
together developers project managers and
contributors to collaborate on software
development it enables businesses to
create and enhance products more quickly
than they could with traditional
software development methods you can use
Azure devops services in the cloud or
Azure devops server on premises
Azure devops has built-in functionality
that you may access via a web browser or
an ID client depending on your business
needs you can use one or more of the
following standard owned services
Azure repos Azure devops a built-in
functionality so for Source management
of your code Azure reports offer git
repositories or team Foundation Version
Control
Azure pipelines build and release
services provided by Azure pipelines to
assess continuous integration and
delivery of your applications
Azure both using carbon and scrum
methodologies Azure both provides a set
of agile tools for planning and tracking
for code bugs and issues Azure test
plans manual and exploratory testing and
continuous testing are among the options
available in Azure test plans for
testing your applications
and at last Azure artifacts this allows
teams to share packages from public and
private sources including Marvin npm
nuget and more and in corporate package
sharing into their pipelines so this
brings us to the features of devops
first we have is dashboard control you
can rapidly navigate to different
regions of the project build and manage
dashboards and set dashboard widgets
using the devops dashboard functionality
then we have improved Source control git
and theme Foundation Version Control a
centralized client server system which
are two prominent methods of source
control supported by Azure devops
solution to observe change history you
can add and manage Azure git tags
reviews downloads and modify files
following that we have plan and track
your work you can utilize Azure devops
systems to track teachers requirements
user stories tasks issues and more using
a variety of work items then we have
integrated collaboration servers Zoom
that allows teams to collaborate
throughout the whole Azure devops
feature set including team dashboards
project Wiki discussion within work item
forms and many others then we have
support for exploratory testing manual
exploratory and continuous testing are
made easier with Azure devops which
include workflow customization
end-to-end traceability criteria based
selection and real-time visualization
that show the test activities and at
last comes continuous integration and
deployment many developers use CI CD and
Azure devops makes it so easy to do so
developers May automate various design
activities with Azure pipelines
including defining and Building
Association steps writing test
instructions and managing simultaneous
releases well this brings us to Azure
devops services
you get an integrated set of services
and tools with Azure devops to manage
your software project from planning to
development to testing and deployment a
client or server model is used to
deliver these Services many of them are
offered via a user-friendly web
interface that works with all media
browsers The Source control build
pipelines and work tracking are just a
few of the services that may be managed
to a client you can see the left pane is
where you access Azure devops Services
as demonstrated in the figure below so
now that we have covered Azure devop
services
let's move on to Azure devops server
Version Control reporting requirements
management project management automated
bills testing and release management are
all capabilities of azure devops server
a Microsoft product it provides devops
features and spans the complete
application cycle so now that we know
what Azure devops services and Azure
develop server are so let's have a crisp
comparison between them to know how
exactly they differ from each other
despite the fact that Azure devops
service is a hosted version of azure
devop server there are seven features
that differ some functions of azure
devops server aren't available in azure
devopservices
so when deciding which platform to use
or considering a transition from
on-premises to the cloud keep the
following points in mind cope and scale
data authentication users and groups and
manage use access so first is scope and
scale data Azure devops services and
Azure devops server are slightly
different
organizations and projects are currently
the only alternatives for scoping and
scaling data Azure devops Services
organization get their own URLs and
always have exactly one project
collection whereas deployments project
collection and projects are the three
methods of scoping and scaling data in
Azure devops server then we have
authentication to connect to Azure
devops services using the public
internet depending on your
organization's Arrangement you can use
Microsoft account credentials or Azure
ad credentials to login you can also
configure Azure ad to require
multi-factor authentication IP address
restriction and other security features
but you connect to an intranet serving
using Azure devops server Windows
authentication and active directory
doming credentials are used to login so
this method is completely open and you
will never be asked to sign in next we
have users and group you may use a
similar technique to Grant access to
groups of users on Azure devops Services
Azure ad groups can be added to Azure
devops Services Group so you must add
users one at a time if you utilize
Microsoft account instead of azure 80.
on the other hand by adding active
directory groups to multiple Azure
devops groups you may chance user access
to deployments in Azure devops server
the membership of AD groups are kept in
sync so users gain and lose access to
Azure devops server as they are added
and withdrawn in Erie and at last there
is manage user access to manage access
to features in Azure devops and Azure
devops server by signing users to an
access level each user in your Azure
devops Services organization must be
assigned an access level as usual as
Visual Studio subscriber sign-in Azure
devops Services verifies them so without
a visual studio subscription you can
give basic access to five users of
coffee whereas all use of azure devops
server is on the honor System specify
the access levels on the administrative
Administration page to set access level
per user based on their license and
assign unlicensed user stakeholder
access only so now that we have covered
all the important features and concepts
of azure devops now let's move on to the
next very important aspect of azure
devops which is azure devops lab
the Azure devop lab is a place where you
can learn about software development and
operations with Azure devops Services
you can simplify and speed up the devops
process it explains how to use Azure
devopservices to automate software
delivery and satisfy business
requirements so to understand it in a
better way let's have a demo of azure
devops lab so let's start with our Azure
devops demo so first what we need to do
is navigate to this
website Azure dot microsoft.in or we can
directly login through
dev.assure.com
you need to do is sign into a Microsoft
Azure account
so after
signing in
he led to this page in that
you just need to click on continue
and here what you need to do is create
an organization under which you're gonna
create your projects multiple projects
and you're gonna attach your team
members to it or group members to it and
we want to give the access
to your projects
so what is the difference between
organization and project is if you have
given anybody access to your
organization or somebody is a part of
your organization then
then that particular individual will
have access to all of your projects but
if you have given somebody only access
to a project then he'll be only
restricted to that particular project
you won't be able to access any other
project that is present under that
particular organization that you both
are part of so basically organization is
something that is used to connect to
groups of or related project or somebody
who is already a part of a particular
organization so here we will give it a
name so I am giving or simply
demo as the organization needs and here
you can see that the projects under this
organization will be hosted under the
South India region
and you need to enter the capture
and click on continue
just a second
so now you can see this saying that it
is taking you to an organization
okay so we already have an organization
of the same name so let's just change it
to something else
let's give it simply demo
org
so here you can see that I see this
thing that it's taking to your Azure
devops organization where you'll be
creating your projects
so now you can see your organization
name
your
and where you just need to create the
project name
so I'm giving it to
simply gem
project
not below you can see the visibility we
can opt either public or private so what
is public or private so basically if uh
you keep it keep the project off if the
visibility of the project public then
once
you copy this
URL
so as I was saying once you copy this
URL into some other browser or incognito
mode
you will be able to have the access to
the project
but if you keep its visibility private
then only the people who have real
access to your organization or to your
project will be able to access that
project or will be able to see that
project or work on it
foreign
this project
and here you can access the statistics
of project how it is performing how much
time they have contributed to it or what
all services you have added to your
project
and down below you'll be able to see
that there is just one member which is
the root user of this project and once
you start adding more members to your
project it will their details will be
added to this particular
block
so now here you can see these other
services boards reports pipelines test
plans
and artifacts services that is provided
to you to add to your project
so now let's have a look
at them one by one
so first one is votes
as we click on boards you can see
multiple options your work items both
backlogs Sprints queries delivery plans
here you can see it is all empty as we
haven't added any service or we haven't
worked on our project yet
let's just click on
new work item
so here you can see one is epic issue
and task
so epic is an option that is uh you can
see a flow option
for work items
so basically epically presents business
initiative to be accomplished and it is
basically available for basic agile
scrum and the cmmi process templates
so what it exactly does is increases
customer engagement that whoever
whatever your project is if it's uh the
engagement
of your project that how it's performing
and how it is performing towards the
people
whom you have given access to the
project also helps to create your
architecture to improve the performance
of your project
and it also support mobile applications
so basically when you're deploying any
mobile application in your project or
creating a mobile application as a
project so it will be able to
support that as well
let's click on it
so here you can see you need to enter a
title for your
epic option
so here we need to add the title of your
epic like for say
we are creating a healthcare or an
e-commerce application so obviously it
will be segmented into different parts
like you'll be having search options or
Support options or home page so we just
need to give with a name
and where you can see its state is to do
for now we just have to do because we
haven't
actually created anything in our project
and we haven't given any input
so it's in to-do list and once we start
working on it it gets we can change the
state it it can be in progress or
completing so there are multiple States
for your Epic
and here you can see the area is simply
done a project that means that we want
to assign this
search you know Epic into this project
and we can also click description over
here that what exactly our new epic is
about like for search options we need to
specify or give a description that
this is for searching options related to
our application like for healthcare one
can type
medicines or
doctors
or slots
so
that is that that is thing that we can
add in our description
that it will help the user to understand
what this feature is about
so this was epic and once done we can
click on Save
so here you can see other
stuffs also like priority
so we can select priority according to
our
will so here by default it is probably
two
Society basically is which function will
come first
and here you can mention start date
Target date
so once it's done you can click on Save
now let's move
to the next one
second what we have is issue
so basically issues are the for you to
track your work
and the epics are used to track the
group work under large scenarios but
this is that like like we saw the
project statistics so it will help you
to understand the individual progress
so basically issues are raised when you
find any obstacle in your
progress or in your work so it can be
compared to impediments also so when
you're working with agile uh
you need to deal with issues so by
default we have agile
to our project assigned so like for
example we can see that uh
we have a meeting so during the meeting
members report if they have encountered
any bug or any any impediments
so what next we have to do is we have to
track them and resolve it so these are
the issues that can
one can find
possibilities
so you can assign here
and give it a description again
and just save it so
once a user faces these issues
we can keep a track of it
and
once it is raised we can resolve it
coming to the
next one
next we have is task
so by the name only we can uh well
understand what task is
so a task is a smaller item or
smaller segment to track activity
that contains all the information needed
to accomplish a part of a of an issue or
you can say user story requirements so
this option is available for basic agile
scrum and cmmi process templates
so again we can give it a name what task
we want to assign
and give it a description
and according to that we can
select the priority
and save it
so the task will be added to your
project
we are not for assigning any task right
now because as I said we haven't added
any uh particular
project or particular details or
application or we haven't deployed any
application yet in a project so that is
why we are not adding anything over here
again because first we need to
understand what these services are and
what these services are used for
next we have backlogs so backlogs helps
you
to understand the flow of your problem
like today you have contributed 10
percent
of your time and you have completed the
10 of the work or you have worked on
certain segments of the project like for
say you have worked in the support area
so it helps you to understand and keep a
track of the flow of your project how it
is performing and how it is developing
and how it is built every day
next we have a string
so Sprints are basically a time box
interval that supports it teams ability
to work using the agile processes and
tools so what we can do is whether
you're having let's say you're having a
healthcare application so you just need
to
have a segment of it and drop it over
here
so what what it will do is uh it will
get the attention of all the team
members so basically what it does it it
makes your project more manageable
it uh increases the quality of your
project and also makes it work even more
faster and more frequently once you add
the segment to the Sprint
so you can see it in one way that's the
priority and people need to work on it
and it gives your project more
flexibility to adapt to change
now now sometimes what happens is many
Associates Trump Sprints with agile
software development
so sometimes
agile often thought to be the same thing
coming to the next one we have queries
so the query page basically remembers
the view you have
last navigated and when you log in again
or when you come back again it's the
same portal it returns you to that very
particular view only
so it can you can say that it runs with
Azure devops command line interface
and all the open uh like all the pages
that you have gone through you can keep
a track of it over here
you just need to click over here all and
you can just see all the queries you
have uh defined in all this while and
also you can share the queries with the
key members
so they can also know that where you
have been working lately
or which segment you have been working
on
or what was the last navigation
which you have been going through in
this whole project
so it can help you manage your project
in a more efficient way
and keep a track of how and what all
segments you have been working on and
what are segments you need to work on in
your project
coming to the next one we have delivery
plans
so here you can see uh we haven't
created any plan yet so basically
delivery plans are a calendar view of
multiple teams or team backlogs or
individual backlogs from different
projects
so basically it replaces the delivery
plans Marketplace extension
and it is only available for Azure
devops services
so here you can hack you can or you can
say it's a summary or a Time summary of
all the projects you have been working
on in a particular organization
so now that we have covered both
let's
move to the next one which is repose
so with the name itself we can well
understand that repo stands for
repositories so basically there's a set
of repositories that allows you to
console and manage your project code
like for say you're deploying a
healthcare application so
these Repose options help you create
repositories and
manage your code of that particular
application and more efficient way
so what you can do is you can connect
project solutions by using the repos
link
as you can see here it is shown
so let's look into its option one by one
first we have
files
so in files your project solution will
be available in this section
so repositories can create manage and
import those Solutions
okay so you just need to upload your
Solutions of your code or your project
here and it will just create
repositories for it and it will help you
create manage those
Solutions in a better way
you can see
here flown to your computer portion
existing repository from command line
and imported repositories if you want to
import any uh solution like here you can
just she got import and add the solution
toward the positive
so this is what files do
basically you can see It'll say it is a
it's like a physical folder itself where
you have all your
main files or reposites or Solutions you
can say of data
so basically it's it functions like a
specific folder itself
so it helps you keep a trackable
records and everything
next comes is comets
so uh in the comment section we can
manage comic history
for your repositories that you have
created in files
so it just commits those repositories
with author details from branches like
per se we have a team one from
support branch and one from management
branch
so
whoever creates that repositories and
have the solution it commits that
repositories under that under that
particular member of the team with the
branch name
then comes pushes
so Bush histories are available in this
section
from each pull request done by the
developers Developers for sale the team
members we who have been working on this
particular project and creating
repositories and solutions
so what is pull request
so pull request or PRS are a way to
change or a review of merge code in our
repositories
so basically team uses these PRS to
review code and get feedbacks or changes
whether like uh for saying you are
deploying a code or a solution
so one can review them what all changes
needs to be named or what all
upgradation needs to be made or whether
the code is already fine or not
so basically teams use these PRS to
review the solutions and codes stored in
these repositories
or you can merge multiple Solutions or
multiple codes into the main branch
so basically the viewers can step
through the proposed changes and and
read those comments
and what to approve or reject that
particular code
or you can say to upgrade or what all
changes you want to make it they vote
for it that whether that needs to be
made to that particular solution or not
so these are the PRS
next we have branches so we can manage
multiple branching information in this
particular section you can create create
or release branches from Master to death
okay so all users
can actually
can actually create or release branches
from branching information available in
this particular section
next come
tags
so tags are used to point out specific
comments
like uh giving message tags and data
information to branches you can create
your name in conventions to branches by
using submit tags
and the second the next one is full
request which we have already discussed
the PRS that are basically used in
pushes
so now we have Commit the completed
Repose also so let's move on to the next
one which is pipeline
so here you can see see that we don't
have any file pipeline
created for us yet so let's have a look
at this provided options one by one
the first one is environments
so basically it is a collection of
resources where you are actually
deploying your application that you're
working on
so it content you can say it contains
one or more virtual machines containers
web apps Etc whatever uh resources you
have actually used for deploying your
application
or model Services you have used for
creating the environment for the
deployment of your application of course
say we need to deploy our application
and it needs an uh
windows
Java environment so whatever resources
you need to create that environment that
will be added to this environment list
it will be listed over
this section
next we have a releases option
so basically this pipeline stores the
data of your pipelines or stages or
tasks
and
deployments in Azure pipelines that
departments you have done so far in your
applications for your applications
actually
so you can say that
it helps your team continuously deliver
software to your customers at a past
pace
with a very minimum you can say lower
risk
so it you can fully automate and
automate the testing and the delivery of
your
software or applications on multiple
stages
or you can also set up an automated
process with approvals and on-demand
deployments
then comes uh Library
so again you can see the page is blank
from the name itself you can scrutinize
that it will be a collection
of assets from
Azure devops projects
basically it is a collection of build
and release assets of a particle project
assets defined in a library can be used
in multiple bills and multiple releases
pipelines of the project
okay so all assets that are defined you
know Library share a common security
model
so you can control who can Define new
items in a library and who can use an
existing item that you have already
added in this Library
or roles are defined for our library
items for say you have added a
particular asset or particular item to
this Library segment
and you can assign a particular member
who will be working on this item
okay so the rules are defined here for
these and these governs the operation
you can perform on those items
that person will be keeping track
whatever changes have been made or
whatever upgradation has been made to
the particular item that has been added
to this
segment Library segment
so then comes uh task groups
so task groups are a way to standardize
and centrally managed deployment steps
for all applications in your projects
so when you include a task group in your
definition and then make a change
centrally to the task group who changes
automatically reflected in all the
definitions
so we can conclude with this that a task
group allows you to encapsulate a
sequence a tasks already defined and you
can say build or release Pipelines or
into a cycle task group
so it just encapsulate all those
sequences tasks
so you can choose to extract the
parameters from those encapsulated tasks
as configured variables
and
abstract the rest of the task
information
so what happens is the new task group is
automatically added to the task catalog
and it is ready to be added to other
release and build Pipelines
so task groups are stored at the project
level and are not accessible outside the
project school so the task groups will
be only limited to the members who you
have assigned in this project and it
won't be accessible to the other people
or other team members from different
projects even though they are the member
of the same organization so you can say
it's more of a private
segment
now that you have trouble touch groups
next we have deployment groups
so deployment groups are only available
with classic release flight Pipelines
and it is totally different from the
deployment jobs
it is basically a collection of
deployment related steps defined in a y
a ml file to accomplish a specific task
so
in nutshell it is a logical set of
deployment Target machines
that have agents installed on each one
the department groups represent the
physical environment for example
testing or development of production
environment
so a Development Group is just another
grouping of Agents much like an agent
pool you can say
so what you can do with this is you can
specify the security context and runtime
targets for the agents or you can let
yourself view live logs for each server
as a deployment take place
or you can also enable you to use
machine tags to limit deployment to a
specific set of
servers
so this was about deployment groups now
that we have covered one more service
let's move on to the next one that is
test plans
so
test plans the first one we have is
progress report
so you can
analyze with this only the progress
report will be the progress of the
project you have been working on or the
deployments you have been doing or the
tasks you have been performing
so
basically it lets you analyze and view
data for
more than one or an individual test
plans in a particular project
data for test plans can migrated can be
migrated from
and on-premises Azure devops server that
won't show up in this report
okay
so basically this section lets you drill
down by each test plans and give you
summary of each test
plan in it the section also lets you to
navigate to a test plan or shoot of
Choice by double clicking on it okay
so this was the progress report next we
have runs
so basically it represents the execution
of Pipelines during a run the pipeline
is processed and regions process one or
more jobs
so when you run a pipeline many things
happen under the couple while you often
won't need to know about them
occasionally it's useful to have the
bigger picture right
so
Azure pipelines will get processed under
this
test runs
segment so you'll be able to see the
water performance
is happening over here like while you're
running a pipeline you can see uh the
running state
the date you have started that
or what all that
returning pipeline includes like job
steps and tasks
runs power both continuous integration
and continuous delivery Pipelines
next we have load test
so basically as your node testing is a
fully managed as Azure service that
enables developers and testers to
generate High scale load with custom
Apache J neuter strips and gain
actionable insights to catch and fix
performance bottlenecks at scale
basically application performance and
resiliency are more important than ever
before
so how you can run an Azure devops test
so first you need to click on it and
select a test suit that contains all the
automated tests
and you can just choose the run test
option
and it will start processing it so the
service this service basically simulates
traffic for your application you can say
regardless of for on which platform or
where it is actually hosted
so now that we have covered test plans
as well let's move on to the next one
that is artifex so this is the last
service that is provided to the project
by azure devops
so artifacts is a
byproducts produced during the software
development process
so it mainly consists of the project
source code dependency or binaries or
resources that could be represented in
different layout depending on the
particular technology
so it's like an extension that makes it
easier
to discover in stone or publish
and Maven packages in azure devops
it's basically deeply integrated with
other hubs like build so that package
management can become a seamless path
for your existing workflows
so what is exactly it is used for so it
basically it can be used
for both public and private organization
with teams of any size it it basically
manages your
npm or nuget packages via feeds and it
allows you to create and share your
makeup
it's a package management solution dated
with your Azure device
this was all about the services that is
provided to your projects so now that
you know what our service is
do for your project and what are their
benefits and how they function now you
can actually plan your project and start
creating and working on it and start
deploying with the users and what all
services you want for your particular
projects so what you can do is click
here on Project setting
just a second
you can just click on Project setting
so now what you can do is you can add in
description that uh what your actual
project is about because I like I said
if you're creating in a healthcare
application so you can just give it a
description that it is for him scan
related to issues queries and helps
needed and like you're trying that
particular application of the system
happens or Healthcare organization so
you can actually add those information
in this description
and the process which basically it is
basic or private one uh but to do get a
range of process
for your project when it depending on
the visibility of it like for agile or
strum you can say
so now here you can see that only my uh
ID is attached to it as I'm the only
members here and I'm the administrator
so you can add members here and
scrolling down you can now that you know
what all services
provide you or what they provide to your
projects the need of your project you
can just
select the services you want to assign
to your particular project like per se
if I don't want both assigned to it or
if you can say if I don't want the
services provided by the code you can
just click on it and select remove both
and I just need to refresh it
so yeah here you can see I have overview
reposed pipelines artifacts but I don't
have uh test plans and Boards as you can
see there's planning is basically all
the collection of whatever you're
managing which is genetically assigned
to both
so as
you remove the test band also get
removed okay
once
like this you can just uh select what
are Services you want specifically and
if you want to delete your project you
can just go ahead and delete it
so this was all about
Azure developed services
and I'll share the workplace Studio we
can see
the demonstration of how a project
actually functions in this virtual
Studio
back in the 2000s organizations were
utterly dependent on purchase servers
for their ID infrastructure these
servers not only came with limited
functionality but were also very
expensive the traditional way of storing
and managing data was costly and
complicated it required a massive amount
of hardware and complex software to run
all these issues were resolved using
cloud computing rather than owning their
Computing infrastructures organizations
were able to scale up or scale down
resources based on the requirement
companies providing these Computing
Services are called as Cloud providers
according to C sharp corner the two
popular Cloud providers in the cloud
Market are Amazon AWS and Microsoft
Azure now let's take a step back and
talk about a question what should an
individual learn in the year 2021
Amazon web services or Microsoft azure
though this question is tricky we need
to understand which cloud provider is
the best option to choose
now let's take a brief look at both of
these Cloud providers
Amazon web services is an evolving cloud
computing platform that offers various
services such as compute power storage
database content delivery and other
resources to help business scale and
grow
AWS services are provided based on a
subscription basis similarly Microsoft
Azure provides a set of cloud services
to design create and monitor
applications on a network
talking about the general features
Amazon web services was established in
the year 2006. today it holds a market
share of
31.7 percent whereas Microsoft Azure was
started in the year 2010 and now has a
market share up to 16.8 percent
Amazon AWS is the world's most broadly
adopted Cloud platform it offers up to
165 Services globally these services are
used by millions of companies like
Spotify Netflix Facebook BBC Etc talking
about Netflix the company moved its ID
operations to AWS in the year 2009. AWS
was able to solve the company's
scalability and data management issues
Azure offers several services in various
categories including artificial
intelligence analytics containers iot
and many more these services are used by
many famous companies like Accenture
LinkedIn stack eBay and Samsung
Accenture chose Microsoft Azure to boost
productivity and provide better security
to its employees
the AWS pricing model is based on an
hourly basis with AWS every individual
pays only for the services that are
required for his work every person only
pays for the services he consumes
Azure pricing is charged on a per minute
basis the payment system is very simple
and doesn't involve any long-term
contracts
Microsoft Azure is free of upfront cost
and cancellation fees and only users pay
for the resources they consume
with Azure and Amazon AWS there are no
additional costs or termination fees
moving on to the next Factor let's talk
about availability zones
availability zones are isolated data
centers with independent power and
networking these zones protect
applications and files from data center
failures in total AWS has nearly 77
availability zones within 24 geographic
regions around the world
the company plans to establish nine more
AWS availability zones and three more
AWS regions in Indonesia Japan and Spain
on the other hand Microsoft Azure has
many isolated availability zones these
zones are located within an Azure region
and they provide fast network
connectivity Azure has 44 availability
zones around the world the company is
planning to launch 12 more zones
now after discussing the availability
zones let's talk about the services the
services that I'm going to compare here
come under the following domains compute
storage database security and finally
networking
AWS and Azure provide a wide variety of
services with low migration costs so
that every individual can shift his or
her current traditional infrastructure
to Cloud platform very easily
AWS ec2 is a suitable example of compute
services
ec2 is a web service that aims to make
life easier for developers by providing
secure and resizable compute capacity in
the cloud it can be integrated to
several other services like S3 IAM cloud
formation
Etc
Azure has a small service called Azure
virtual machine image it helps the
developers to develop and design
identical virtual machines in the matter
of minutes
Azure virtual machines are becoming more
popular among it infrastructures these
machines let an individual create and
use Virtual machines in the cloud as
iaas or infrastructure as a service
virtual machines can be created using
Azure portal Azure Powershell and arm
templates Azure CLI or client software
development kits next comes Amazon S3 it
is the best example for storage service
simple storage service is an object
storage service designed to store and
recover any information from anywhere
via the Internet
Amazon S3 facilitates storage through a
web service interface the service
provides 99.9 durability and 99.9
percent availability of objects
it has the capacity of storing computer
files up to 5 terabytes in size
on the other hand Azure provides a
similar service called blob storage
service
this service provides a large amount of
storage and is highly scalable it stores
an object in the tires depending on how
often the data is being accessed blob
storage supports widely used Frameworks
like java.net Python and node.js it is
the only cloud storage service in
Microsoft Azure that offers a premium
SSD based object storage tire for low
latency Networks
AWS provides a secure Cloud platform
where every individual can manage and
deploy their applications compared to
the on-premises environment AWS Security
offers a high level of data protection
at a lower cost for security purposes
IEM is a suitable service AWS identity
and access management is a cloud service
that controls and manages AWS resources
securely it has no upfront cost also
gives a facility to create and maintain
services within a specific set of users
on your AWS resources in Microsoft Azure
Azure active directory or in short also
called as Azure ad is a web service
which provides MFA multi-factor
authentication features to users in
order to protect their data from cyber
attacks next is Amazon RDS it is a web
service designed to simplify the setup
operation and scaling of a relational
database it is simple to set up use and
scale when required by users it provides
inexpensive and resizable capacity and
automates several tasks such as Hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups on the other side the Azure SQL
database automatically updates and
backups data in order to focus on the
development of applications not just
that it also manages database services
and response to client requirements
client requirements such as scalability
of a service data backup and high
availability of database
similarly these Cloud providers have
plenty of services that help users build
and deploy their applications
effectively
moving on to the next topic let us focus
on integrating AWS and Azure with open
source tools now we will explain how to
build a pipeline using Jenkins along
with one of the services of Amazon web
services that is the ec2 in this
integration process we have a sample
python application called as a Docker
file
this Docker file will consist of a
python base image
the docker file builds a pipeline in
order to create a Docker image upon
pushing the code to the respository
later the new image is used to start a
new AWS service on an ECS cluster
now let's have a look at how the
integration of Open Source tools happen
in Azure in your Azure Cloud application
devops tools like Docker Maven and
Jenkins can be integrated in case you
want to integrate the Jenkins pipeline
go to project and create a subscription
followed by Jenkins you can specify the
required filters based on your
requirement then choose your endpoint
for Azure devops to communicate with
Jenkins
so that was all about Amazon AWS and
Microsoft Azure both AWS and Azure are
honored to be on top of all other Cloud
providers both provide all necessary
features like scalability high
availability and security
but the moment I hear about choosing the
best one I have to say that all that
depends upon the individual business
needs both Cloud providers are the
certified ones that hold immense value
in the current cloud service Market hey
guys I'm Rahul and I'll be representing
Amazon web services I'm chinmayi and
I'll be representing Microsoft Azure and
I am Shruti and I'll be representing
Google Cloud platform so welcome to this
video on AWS versus Azure versus gcp
talking about market share Amazon web
services leads with around 32 percent of
the worldwide public cloud share Azure
owns up to 16 of the worldwide market
share and gcp owns around nine percent
of the world's market share let's talk
about each of these service providers in
detail AWS provides services that enable
users to create and deploy applications
over the cloud these services are
accessible via the Internet AWS being
the oldest of the lot was launched in
the year 2006. Azure launched in 2010 is
a Computing platform that offers a wide
range of services to build manage and
deploy applications on the network using
tools and Frameworks launched in the
year 2008 gcp offers application
development and integration services for
its end users in addition to Cloud
management it also offers services for
Big Data machine learning and iot now
let's talk about availability zones
these are isolated locations within data
center regions from which public cloud
services originate and operate talking
about AWS they have 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical regions
this includes regions in the United
States South America Europe and Asia
Pacific they are also predicted to have
12 more additions in the future Azure
available in 140 countries has over 54
regions worldwide grouped into six
geographies these geographical locations
have more than 100 data centers gcp is
available in 200 plus countries across
the world as of today gcp is present in
61 zones and 20 regions with Osaka and
Zurich being the newly added regions now
let's talk about about pricing these
Services follow the pay as you go
approach you pay only For The Individual
Services you need for as long as you use
them without requiring long-term
contracts or complex licensing now on
screen you can see the pricing for each
of these cloud service providers with
respect to various instances like
general purpose compute optimized memory
optimized and GPU now let's talk about
the compute services offered first off
we have virtual servers for AWS we have
ec2 it is a web service which eliminates
the need to invest in Hardware so that
you can develop and deploy applications
in a faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that Azure offers Azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcp's VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these Services awcc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
Linux and Windows Virtual machines Azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to Windows and Linux
virtual machines gcp's VM service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or past services for AWS elastic
Beanstalk is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java.net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing Auto scaling and
application Health monitoring the past
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual Hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying Hardware Google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by Developers
for hosting and building apps in Google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in Java or Python and
store data in Google bigtable and use
the Google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
Services AWS provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM image is a more comprehensive image
for Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp Cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers First off we
have object storage AWS provides S3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in Microsoft's Cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tiers depending on how often
data is being accessed Google Cloud
Storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google Cloud Storage is
more suitable for Enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets Amazon provides EBS or elastic
Block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
Azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 VM
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off Google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either Google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have Disaster Recovery Services
AWS provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database Services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the user's applications
Cloud SQL is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
MySQL and SQL Server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud SQL provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database Services AWS provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance Azure Cosmos DB is
Microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by Google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your applications load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment Target now
let's talk about the key Cloud tools for
each of these service providers for AWS
in networking and content delivery we
have AWS Route 53 and AWS cloudfront for
management we have AWS cloud watch in
AWS cloud formation for development we
have AWS code start and AWS code build
for security we have IAM and Key
Management Service for Microsoft Azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery Network and express
route for management tools we have Azure
advisor and network Watcher for
development tools for management we have
Azure advisor and network Watcher for
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and Azure blob studio for security we
have Azure security Center and Azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have Cloud CDN and
Cloud DNS for management we have
stackdriver and gcp monitoring for
development we have Cloud build and
Cloud SDK and finally for security we
have Google cloud IM and Google and
Cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these Cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix
Unilever Kellogg's NASA Nokia and Adobe
Pixar Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW
among others use my Microsoft Azure so
as seen on your screens the companies
that use gcp are Spotify HSBC Snapchat
Twitter PayPal and 20th Century Fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these Services Amazon provides
Enterprise friendly Services you can
leverage Amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale Global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources AWS is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new SAS based
application Speed and Agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable Amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise and buy
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure Microsoft Azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
Azure has a strong focus on security
following the Standard Security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close Azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an ID
infrastructure costs hence it's Opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp Google bills in minute
level increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use they also provide
discounted prices for long-running
workloads for example you use the VM for
a month and get a discount gcp also
provides live migration of virtual
machines live migration is the process
of moving or running VM from one
physical server to another without
disrupting its availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for Google Cloud compared to other Cloud
providers gcp provides automatic
scalability ability this allows a size
container scale to as many CPUs as
needed Google Cloud Storage is designed
for 99.9 durability it creates server
backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for AWS there's a limitation of the ec2
service AWS provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee AWS charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than 100 an Enterprise that
costs more than fifteen thousand dollars
it has certain network connectivity
issues it also has General issues when
you move to the cloud like downtime
limited control backup protection and so
on however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of Microsoft Azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass ecosystem is not as
efficient as iaas Azure Management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks Azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal industry stores of servers in a
remote data center let's now look into
the disadvantages of gcp so when it
comes to Cloud providers the support fee
is very minimal but in the case of gcp
it is quite costly it is around 150
dollars per month for the most basic
service similar to AWS S3 gcp has a
complex pricing schema also it is not
very budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from Google Cloud
Storage knowing Azure is one thing
having worked on Azure is another thing
and being able to answer interview
questions in Azure is a totally
different thing although one helps the
other it's still different skills and
our aim through this video is to prepare
you with common product and scenario
based interview questions so why wait
let's get started a common Cloud
interview question is what's the
difference between SAS pass and is we
all know that a software as a service is
Thin Client model of software
provisioning where client in this case
usually is simply a web browser
providing the point of access to
softwares running on the servers now SAS
is the most familiar form of cloud
service for customers SAS moves the task
of managing software and its deployment
to third-party services meaning the
vendor actually gets to manage all that
so SAS is software as a service
involving applications being consumed
and used by organization so it's
generally using an application and
usually organizations pay for their use
of this particular application now some
example of SAS would include Office 365
Salesforce is another very good example
of SAS and a lot of Google Apps and
Storage Solutions like box and Dropbox
are a very good example of software as a
service talking about platform as a
service or pass it actually functions at
the lower level than SAS now typically
it provides a platform on which software
can be developed and deployed now here
we developed the software we deploy the
software now Paz actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client and
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
Hardwares the network are managed and
taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
that I've mentioned like these servers
the server software the hardware
everything is managed by the provider
and we can focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of pass
in Azure is SQL and Azure storage
talking about infrastructure as a
service I as now this is moving down the
stack even further now we get to the
fundamental building block of the cloud
service which is infrastructure as a
service is now is is fully of Highly
automated scalable Computer Resources is
full of storage is full of the network
capability that's what is now is clients
have direct access to the servers and
storage just as they would to do
traditional service but in this case
it's going to be in the cloud in this
case it's going to be more scalable so
is very similar to what you would do in
your on-premises physical data center
but when we talk about is we get to do
everything but it's stored in the cloud
so if we need to build a definition
around is is or infrastructure as a
service provides users with components
it provides components it does not give
us a built environment it simply
provides a component such as operating
system a networking capabilities and a
lot more now this is a paid for based on
the usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of is in
Azure is a virtual machine that's a
great example for is and v-nets for
networking that's another good example
for is in Azure another common question
in Azure interview is so what are the
instant types offered by Azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in Azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and there are there are a lot of
services in Azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate service so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by Azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product and services available in Azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement you shouldn't be
provisioning more you should be
provisioning less at the same time so
it's kind of matching the right service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by Azure as you
see in the list we have general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized
storage optimized GPU virtual machines
and hyper performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in What scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for computer optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
VMS you know they provide a balanced CPU
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers small to
medium databases some Enterprise grade
applications it's also good for
relational database it's also good for
servers used for in-memory caching it's
also good for some small analytic
database very good for Microsoft
services and if you're trying to build a
proof of concept for an idea that you
just have or just parked this is another
good server for doing proof of Concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it I just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 V3 which comes
with 256 gigabit of memory and 1600
gigabit of SSD temporary storage on the
other hand compute optimized VMS have an
a high CPU to memory ratio and are very
good for medium traffic web servers very
good for batch processing servers very
good for application servers now because
it's computer optimized and compute
means a CPU it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster CPU but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual CPU some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads gaming servers require more
CPU they run really well batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in a computer
optimized and by doing that we get the
actual benefit of the compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72s a V2 and here we get 144
gigabit of memory and 576 gigabit of SSD
temporary storage in compute optimized
VMS in the same lines memory optimized
to VM they offer High memory to CPU
ratio and that are great for databases
databases require more memory so it's a
great fit for a database and it's a
great fit for medium to large scale
caches applications that require
in-memory analytics so this memory
optimized memories more so it's very
good for in-memory analytics
applications and the largest instance
size we get here is standard
m128m and look at the gigabit of memory
it's a 3892 gigabit of memory and look
at the temporary storage it's a 1400
336 a gigabit of temporary storage on
the same lines storage optimized now I
guess I don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have easily guessed looking at the
flow yes storage optimized VM offer High
disk throughput and IO and are very
ideal for Big Data SQL nosql databases
data warehousing servers large
transactional databases and lot more and
some of the examples of the applications
that can be launched on storage
optimized are Cassandra mongodb cloud
redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disk on the
Node attached directly to the VM rather
than using an durable disk which is
actually an a remote disk space now what
does this allow this allows for greater
input outputs per second or throughput
for the workload so that's what we get a
greater throughput a greater input
outputs per second is what we get and
when we use storage optimized and the
largest instance size available in
storage optimized is standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the temporary storage it's a
5630 gigabit of temporary storage GPU
type VMS easy to guess at GPU optimized
VMS are are specialized virtual machines
available with multiple gpus attached to
them now these sizes are designed for or
these VMS are designed for computer
intensive graphic intensive
visualization workloads that require a
lot of graphical Processing Unit
attached to it so in short these are
virtual machines that specialize in
heavy graphic rendering and video
editing it also helps with model
training and interferencing with a
standard nd24 RS which has 448 gigabit
of memory and 2948 gigabit of temporary
storage and the last but not the least
but the best last but the best is high
performance compute or Azure H series
virtual machines now they are the latest
in high performance Computing VMS and
are aimed to handle workloads like batch
processing analytic molecular modeling
and fluid dynamics a lot of complicated
applications in this VM and this is the
fastest and Powerful CPU virtual machine
with the optional High throughput
interfaces and the largest instance size
that's available is a standard l32s
which comes with the 224 gigabit of
memory and 200 gigabit of SSD temporary
storage and a third common question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by Azure there are two main
deployment environments one is the
staging environment and the other one is
the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you are deploying
a web app or web app on Linux you can
deploy them to a separate slot instead
of the default production slot when
running them in standard premium or
isolated app service plan tiers now the
deployments slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point the staging environment can be
swapped with the production environment
so why do we need an staging environment
what are the benefit of it so the
benefit of deploying an application to a
non-production or staging environment it
provides a platform to validate changes
to our application before it can be made
live in the production environment and
in the staging environment the app can
be identified using the azure's global
unique identifier also called as the
guid URL and it's very very similar to
the production URL except that it has a
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment this is
the live production environment that's
serving customers request that serving
the customer content now it can be
slightly different from the staging
environment in a way that the URL that's
used to identify the production
environment that's more often DNS
friendly name like the name of the
actual service dot
cloudapp.net that way it differs in case
of staging environment you have a custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloudapp.net but in this
case you get the direct service name as
the name of the URL so this is live
production environment which receives
and handles and serves customer traffic
another commonly asked question in Azure
is what are the advantages of scaling in
Azure the actual thought behind the
question is to see how much have you
understood scaling how much have you
seen and how much have you applied the
scaling effect in the production
environment and have received benefits
in return so let's talk about it
advantages of scaling in Azure some of
the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now Auto scaling
is a built-in feature for the cloud
services be it AWS Azure Google and
couple of other cloud service providers
it's a built-in feature for a cloud
service a cloud service should be Auto
scalable and that includes mobile
services virtual machines and when we
run our applications on mobile services
or virtual machines the website actually
gets the best performance during the
change in the demand again a different
applications might require different
performance needs for example for some
apps the performance measured based on
memory and another a good example is the
fluctuating demand for example you could
have a web app that handles millions of
requests during the day and literally
nothing at the night and auto scaling
this environment Auto scaling any of
these environment will automatically
scale or fatten your environment so to
receive the all the incoming traffic and
during lean period it actually gets
Slimmer and Slimmer so to help you with
the cost so if it actually maximizes the
performance that's what Auto scaling
does and like we said Auto scaling
scales up and scales Down based on
demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic then we can very well go
ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that Monday to Friday
that's the traffic that I would get and
it's a constant one it's not a public
facing but you know it's an internal
application so I know all the 500 users
or the Thousand or the 5000 users who
will be using it so at any given point
it's just 5000 users it's not going to
go beyond that and during Saturday and
Sunday utterly nobody's going to be in
office so no load at all so in that case
I pretty much know how the pattern is
going to be I can go for scheduled
scaling if I know at the pattern and
auto scaling like I said not only helps
with keeping the application highly
available it also helps with the cost
effectiveness of our infrastructure so
anytime there's a VM or a group of VMS
running on less CPU Auto scaling is
going to actually get the environment
Slimmer and Slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you are being
interviewed for the infra site in Azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are Windows Active
Directory and Azure active directory
different let's talk about the Windows
Active Directory first the non-cloud
Windows Active Directory was the service
was released along with Windows 2000
server Edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and lot of
other on-premise sources are resources
that's what the basic non-cloud active
directory does on the other hand the
Azure active directory is not designed
to manage a web-based Services the Azure
active directory on the other hand was
designed to support web-based services
that use rest API interfaces for Office
365 salesforce.com
Etc unlike the plain active directory
this uses an completely different
protocol so protocol wise it's different
and the services that it support is
quite different now besides that it also
has couple of other differences as well
and let's look at them so the actual
active directory or the windows actual
directory is a directory service that
facilitates working with interconnected
complex and different network resources
in a very unified manner on the other
hand Azure active directory is
Microsoft's multi-tenant cloud-based
directory and identity management
service and the Windows Active actually
has five layers to store data to store
user details and to issue the management
certifications on the other hand Azure
active directory integrates or
compresses the five layers into just two
layers here Windows Active Directory
works with on-premises servers like
applications file servers and printers
Etc on the other hand Azure active
directory it works on web-based services
that use restful interfaces if you're
being hired for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of cues offered by
Azure now Azure supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage queue and
the service bus queue Let's Talk About
Storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
base based interface simple rest based
get put and Peak interface it provides
reliable persistent messaging within and
between other services it follows the
pub sub model or a pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80
gigabit of messages in the queue it can
provide a logs for all the transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with storage queue
and on the other hand service bus queue
the service bus queues are built on top
of broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications and applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span multiple communication
protocols and even different totally
different network environments so in
short these service buses or the service
bus queues in Azure are part of azure's
messaging infrastructure and they
integrate applications or application
components that can actually span
multiple different protocols and
multiple different network environments
it also provides an first and first out
style for delivery and the user's queue
size has to remain under 80 gigabit
another familiar question is what are
the advantages of azure resource manager
now this resource manager helps us to
manage the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually tests how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to when doing
deployments or when provisioning
resources without the resource manager
so let's get into the answers for the
question what are the advantages of
azure resource manager the in-shared
resource manager is called arm so the
arm helps deploy manage and monitor all
the result sources for an application a
solution or a group so all the
interconnected application all the
interconnected Services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and a
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account I can
have like 10 different resources created
by resource manager or a resource Group
created by resource managers and I can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those Services based on
whether the user should be accessing one
and not accessing the other so that way
it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using Azure zos
manager and provisioning resources is
made much easier with the help of this
resource manager another question is how
has integrating hybrid Cloud been useful
for Azure well with the use of hybrid
Cloud we get the best of both the worlds
so what's hybrid Cloud it's nothing but
combining the public cloud and the
private cloud and allowing data and
applications to be shared between them
so whenever the compute or the
processing demand fluctuates hybrid
cloud computing gives businesses the
ability to seamlessly scale their
on-premises infrastructure in the public
cloud and handle any kind of
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps it boost the productivity
of our on-premises application so with
the hybrid Cloud we get a greater
efficiency with combination of azure
services at devops processes and tools
for the application running in
on-premises and by having an hybrid
Cloud environment users can take
advantage of a constantly updated azure
service and other AWS Marketplace
applications for their on-premises
environment and the other benefit is
with hybrid Cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on-premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on-premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater speed what's federating in
Azure SQL now this question is very
specific about SQL how can we scale the
SQL database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out the
databases the theory of scaling out or
adding servers to accommodate the
increased workflows and traffic is not
hard to understand but the implications
can be very complicated the implications
can be very expensive we're well aware
of scaling the web service that's very
common but how do we scale the database
so Microsoft provides the tools and
Technologies so we can scale out the
database in the cloud and that's what is
called SQL or Federation in Azure SQL so
the way we scale out the SQL database is
by sharing sharing the database so
sharing actually enables users to take
advantages of the resources in the cloud
not only that it allows users to have
their own database or a Shad database
amongst each other because we're
creating a highly available database
because we're having shards in a
database it actually reduces the
possibility of a single point of failure
for our database and more importantly
because we're sharing because we're
using Federation and Azure SQL it
provides an cost effective scaling of
our database cases by using Cloud
resources or by using billing only for
the cloud resources that we have used so
no pre-provisioning no over provisioning
it Provisions the right amount and we
pay the right amount let's talk about
this one what are the different types of
storage offered by Azure now the
different types of storage offered by
Azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are Azure blob storages
table storages file storage and queue
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and Azure blob storage is uh
Microsoft's object storage solution for
the cloud now lob storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
unstructured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the format of pictures music
video files and lot more and it stores
them along with their metadata and
another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage is
when an object is changed it is verified
to ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an URL or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with The Blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema Less
storage of secured data now this Azure
table storage is a service that stores
structured no SQL data in the cloud and
because this table is schema-less it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your data as the need for
your application grows and this table
storage is very fast and cost effect for
many type of applications so some of the
some of the type of data that we can
store is table storage is good for
flexible databases like user data for
web applications address book storage
device information storage and if you
want to store metadata this is a very
good use case to store them in Azure
table storage Azure files is another
storage here it's a managed file share
for cloud or on-premises deployment so
file storage provides a file sharing
capabilities accessible by the server
messaging block protocol and this can be
accessed from the cloud and this can be
accessed from on-premises as well now
here in file storage the data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and https protocols
and the more important thing is azure
takes care of managing hardware and the
operating system deployments for Azure
file storage so this additional file
storage can be used when we want to
burst the storage capacity in
on-premises so on-premises the primary
and cloud is the secondary or the
extended on-premises storage so it
actually improves the on-premises
performance and capabilities for our
on-premises data center and then we have
cues Azure queues it's a messaging store
for Reliable messaging between the
application components so we spoke a
little about this in the previous
question so the Azure queue storage is a
service for storing a large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world via HTTP or https
a protocol and here the a single message
can be up to 64 kilobits in size and in
a queue we can have millions of messages
and the limit can actually go up if we
have not reached the limit of the
storage account so it's millions and
millions of requests that can be stored
in the storage tube or the the queue
storage so the queue storage in short
provides message queuing for large
workloads and it enables users to build
flexible applications and separate the
functions one from another so one
failing doesn't affect the other
application which is running healthy and
this queue storage it ensures the
application is scalable and less prone
to individual component failures because
they are decoupled separate now it also
helps in monitoring the queue which
ensures the customer's demands are met
so Q is a great place to monitor or a
great component to monitor so we
understand how much a peak have you
reached for a particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis API in Azure machine learning
now a text analysis is actually an cloud
based analytics API and it provides an
advanced natural language processing
over the raw text and it has got four
main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the key phrase analysis
language deduction and few other things
now what do you mean by sentiment
analysis now sentiment analysis is from
the logs from the commands from the text
commands that we receive I do an
analysis and find out whether that's an
positive or A negative statement now if
it is a the API the API returns and the
sentiments code between 0 and 1 and 1 is
positive and 0 is negative and then in
text analysis we have a key phrase
extraction which is it will
automatically extract the key phrase to
quickly identify the main points in that
key phrase for example if you're
analyzing an text which says the food
was delicious and there were wonderful
stuff then the API Returns the main
talking points of that phrase like food
food is the main talking point and one
of full staffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this text analysis has and then we have
language deduction in text analysis
right irrespective of what you paste it
can try to gauge and try to align it to
the 120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so I can simply take text from
the internet and I can paste it and the
text analysis software is going to
identify the language and then can run
phrase and sentiment analysis on those
texts right so in short text analysis is
an API a set of web services that can be
used for text analysis it can be used to
analyze unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between 0 and 1 and 1 being positive and
0 being the negative sentiment there is
no much training or in other words this
is not as complicated as couple of other
text analysis softwares are available in
the market we can simply paste we can
simply upload the text and we can call
the service and it runs a sentiment
analysis on it all by itself let's look
at this question what are the advantages
of azure queue storage if you're going
to work in a development environment if
you're going to work on an environment
that Embraces devops this could be a
question what are the advantages of
azure queue storage now Azure queue
storage is built to flexibly operate the
applications and separate the functions
between the applications that run large
workloads so when we design applications
for scale these applications can be
decoupled so that they can scale
independently you know and think
happening on an application is not
dependent on another application and
anything happens to an section of the
application will not affect the other
application because they are now
decoupled and corrected through the
queue storage so the queue storage gives
us as asynchronous message queuing for
communication between the applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises or on mobile devices so in
short this queue storage enables message
queuing for large workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages advantages
is it provides Rich client libraries for
Java Android C plus plus PHP Ruby and
lot other services getting added during
every new release from Azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and separate the
functions for bigger or greater
durability again introduction of queues
into our application it ensures our
users applications are scalable and less
prone to individual component failures
meaning one component failing is not are
going to take the whole application down
right if one component fails it's just
that component that stays fails the rest
are healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
cues and ensure the servers are
overhelmed by sudden traffic a burst so
how much do I have in the queue kind of
determines the traffic for my
application and if the queue is more I
can always go and auto scale my
environment and the queue is less I can
always go and Shrink or make my
environment thinner so it can save cost
and anytime there is more data in the
queue I can Auto scale monitor the
metric and do auto scaling based on that
metric so the environment knows that
there are more data's coming in I need
to expand myself to handle that much
amount of data this is a very common
question what are the two kinds of azure
web service roles now a service role is
a set of managed and load balanced
virtual machines that work to perform
some tasks and they based on what it's
going to run on top of it is it going to
run a web service or is it going to run
a worker service defines what kind of
roles that gets attached or that goes on
this virtual machines so we have two
types web role and worker roles the web
role is a cloud service role that's
configured to run web applications
developed on programming languages
Technologies and majorly they support
IIs internet information service and
they support asp.net PHP Windows
communication foundation and so on so
that's web roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the user's IIs
internet information service on the
other hand worker roles are roles that
runs applications and service level
tasks which generally do not require IAS
so IIs is actually the differentiating
factor so in worker roles is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and or doing some changes in the
database getting new messages from the Q
and processing and lot more you know the
work the applications or the work that
does not require IES that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web role and the
worker role is that the web role
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use IIs and runs
our application as Standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so Azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage a scalable and
reliable microservices and containers
now service fabric also addresses some
of the significant challenges in
developing and managing cloud native
applications and the problem that IT
addresses and fixes is now developers
and administers can avoid complex
infrastructure problems and focus on
implementing Mission critical and
demanding workloads that can be scaled
and that can be managed through the
console or from the single place in
short service fabric provides a platform
that makes the process of developing
microservices and managing application
life cycle a lot easier and the
advantages of service fabric is that now
we can produce application with faster
time to Market because all the worry
about the infrastructure is taken away
from us we don't have to design an
infrastructure all that we need to worry
about is simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports Windows it
supports Linux not only that it supports
servers on premises and in the cloud
with service fabric we can scale up our
environment to even thousand machines in
just a single command or if there is a
immediate need for thousand machines I
can immediately scale them up to
thousand machines that's possible with
service fabric now let's look at this
question you can expect this question if
the customer is running hybrid
environment meaning having some of the
applications in on-premises and running
some of the applications from the cloud
and for some reason when classifying the
application that goes to the cloud and
that stays on premises they have decided
to keep the database in-house so in that
environment a lot of customers do that
so in that environment this is a classic
and a scenario based question a client
wants the front end of their application
to be hosted on Azure in the cloud and
once the database to be hosted in
on-premises for security reasons or to
have full control on that databases how
do we go about suggesting a solution for
this customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use the v-net based point
to site VPN solution so all different
content applications will be in the
cloud and they'll be hosted in a v-net
and from the v-net they'll be connecting
to the database through and point to
site or VPN so the traffic and the
writings and the reads are not coming
through the internet but through a point
to site VPN link that's connecting the
Azure v-net and the on-premises
environment and this model or this
approach or the solution is best suited
for scenarios where there are only a
limited number of results that needs to
be connected between on-premises and the
cloud this is a very common question
what's Azure traffic manager of course
we know more running applications on a
single server we know more running
applications on or or from a single
environment right the same application
is being run from multiple environments
within Azure and it can be running from
Azure and on-premise as well so multiple
environments between Azure and
on-premises and a lot of customers have
such environment and if you are facing
an interview you with such customer this
could be an ideal question what is azure
traffic manager now the Azure traffic
manager is a dns-based traffic load
balancer that actually enables us to
distribute traffic between Services
across Azure Global regions and by doing
this it provides a good availability and
a good responsiveness to the application
and this traffic manager it uses DNS to
direct client requests to the most
appropriate service endpoint based on
the traffic routing logic and the health
of the endpoints that it maintains so in
short this traffic manager is a load
balancer that enables users to provide
High availability and responsiveness by
Distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the Azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using Azure traffic manager
is it provides multiple automatic
failover options a it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with Azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual Network and
now we need to move them or create a
separation between them how do you go
about achieving it so the question goes
like this you need to isolate Network
traffic among VMS in a subnet which is
part of a virtual network with little
downtime and impact on the user so
that's the given scenario and the best
way we can do it is create a new virtual
Network and move all the VMS in that
subnet to the new virtual Network now
this feature is not possible with a lot
of other cloud service providers like
AWS and lot of other providers now in
those environments we might need to shut
down we might need to stop the VM create
a new VM based on the image and it's an
Hefty process but here in Azure I can
simply move the VMS from one subnet to
another virtual Network without needing
for any additional security like the
network security group I can simply
isolate them if I need to by creating a
simple a new virtual Network and moving
the servers to the new virtual Network
look at this one this is another common
question with respect to Azure what is
public private and hybrid Cloud so this
is really to test how well have you
understood the different Cloud offerings
in the market public private and hybrid
or at least the three basic offerings in
the market public private and hybrid
Cloud now the public cloud is the most
common way of deploying cloud computing
applications and it has resources like
servers storage and our own and operated
by third-party cloud service providers
like Microsoft Azure Microsoft Azure is
a very good example of public Cloud so
here every component that the user is
using is running only on Azure that's
public Cloud right let me talk to you
about some of the advantages of public
Cloud some of the advantages is low cost
because there's no need to purchase
Hardware or software and we pay only for
the services that we use in public cloud
and there is literally no maintenance
because the service provider maintains
the environment for us and with public
Cloud we have nearly unlimited
scalability meaning we can get resources
on demand and can meet our business
requirements on demand and the public
clouds are very highly reliable because
they have a vast network of servers and
they ensure that our application does
not fail so there are some advantages of
public Cloud let's talk about private
Cloud now private Cloud consists of
compute resources used extensively by
one business or one organization now
this private Cloud can be physically
located at our organizations on-site
data center or it can be hosted by a
third-party service provider whichever
the case the private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private Network and they're maintained
on hardware and software that are
dedicated solely for one organization or
solely for your organization so in short
private cloud in Azure is azure Services
being run within an on-premises data
center or on-premises data center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security resources are not shared with
others so have higher level of control
and security over our resource and
application is possible and then we have
a hybrid Cloud now hybrid cloud is the
best of both worlds so it combines the
features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on Azure and others within
on-premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in
on-premises and half of them would be in
the cloud and they will be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid Cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood the Azure products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data so there are a lot of storage
options available and the requirement
here is what or which one would you
choose for unstructured data the answer
for that question is block storage
because blob storage is designed to
support unstructured data it works in
this way it places the data into
different tiers based based on how often
they are accessed different tier means
different performance different
performance means different cost
associated with it so a lot of add-on
advantages will we get when we use blob
storage for unstructured data in
addition to it any type of unstructured
data can be stored in a blob storage
this is not true with couple of other
storage options that we have in Azure
only with blob storage we can store any
type of unstructured data and the data
Integrity is maintained every time an
object is changed in the blob storage
and the best part is the blob storage
helps increase applications performance
and reduces the bandwidth consumption
for that application so they are the
benefits that we get for Block storage
and blob storage are the ones that are
well suited for unstructured data and
that's what your answer should be it's
really an five-step process and if you
have worked and if we have done some
Labs some basic Labs with azure you can
easily answer this question so it's a
five-step process first step is to log
into the Azure the second one is to
create an resource resource or a
resource manager and within the resource
manager you will be selecting the
resource and then pick the offering
system do you want windows or Linux and
within Windows what's the flavor you
want or within Linux what's the flavor
you want so decide on it and then
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the name of
the instance or the VM that we're going
to launch and the password the URL that
goes with it and couple of other
relevant information that goes gets
itself attached with the VM and then
select the size of the virtual machine
different size different types available
for the kind of application and for the
intensity of the application that will
be running on top of it so select the
virtual select the size of the virtual
machine review everything whether
they're good or not if there are any
changes required go back and edit them
and then come back and launch and your
VM is there for you to start working
within like three or four minutes not
even five minutes within three or four
minutes it gets ready and you can start
working on it so it's a quick and it's a
five step process and you should be able
to answer it easily if you have done a
few labs in Azure let's now look at some
scenario based question you've been
posed with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based questions that are being
asked in interview and I thought we'll
present it for you with the answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual Network in Azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
Network users can pick their own private
IP ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets a lot
more goes into that virtual Network so
it's very customizable and the users are
provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual Network that we own So within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and of course all
traffic stays within the Azure Network
Azure virtual machine or within the
Azure Network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to to go or reach the Internet
it's going to go otherwise it's going to
stay within Azure if you have set up
routing to reach on-premises then it's
going to go and reach on-premises
otherwise it's not going to go and reach
on premises it's going to stay within
the Azure and it also allows users to
design their own network like we already
discussed picking up IPS picking routing
you know picking subnets you know how
many servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the IP ranges the natting
the masking of ips creating of VPN all
that's possible with the virtual Network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they log in ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that no wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hassle free so they're not
asked to re-enter the password or the
same password again and again let's look
at the options available the first one
is to enable Microsoft account
authentication well it's not going to
fix because with that the user will
still need to re-enter the username and
password at deploy express route it's
not going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on-premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have set up VPN between
on-premises Data Center and Azure setup
80 domain controller in VM and Implement
integrated Windows authentication well
you can use the same username and
password for on-premises and the cloud
but this setup the VPN and the area
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeated passwords so
this is all about using the same
password in on-premises and in the cloud
and this has got nothing to do with not
prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's same
password is different from not prompting
the user to re-enter the password there
are two different scenarios so that is
also out of the equation and the last
one is configure ad sync to use single
sign-on that's the right one so when we
configure the ad to use a single sign on
then it's going it's not going to ask
for the username and password every time
we access an application because we have
logged in and that login is going to
stay active for like 20 for hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
Azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is is literally and DNS service and then
let's look at the other one update
domains it again has to do with traffic
manager updating the URL so the traffic
manager gets updated and then starts
sending requests to that particular URL
it's going to take some down time
because when we update the URL they will
have to be populated to all different
places and it takes time so within that
time any user trying to access it's
going to fail and then we have express
route and cloud services express route
could be the in fact it's the right
answer because express route it's an
extension of our on-premises and Cloud
environment and in this question it
really comes out from a customer who's
having an hybrid environment so they
have applications running in on-premises
they have applications running in the
cloud and they want to have a way to
migrate applications from on-premises to
the cloud in other words kind of do a
cut over between on-premises and the
cloud and this express route is a
service that connect between on-premises
and the cloud so when you do the cut
over the traffic is now sent to the
cloud instead of being handled in
on-premises in fact the services and the
application is getting down are getting
shut down in on-premises so the request
will come in the same pattern instead of
there being handled in on-premises they
are now routed to the cloud using
express route and the API calls get
addressed or the the queries gets
answered in the cloud through the
express route service look at this
question you are an administrator for a
website called Web game and you're
required to validate and deploy changes
made to your website by your development
team with minimum downtime so the real
question is how do you validate the
deployment changes that's made by the
development team let's look at the
options create a new linked resource
create a staging environment for the
site enable remote debugging on the
website and then create a new website
well why would you want to create a new
website just to validate the changes and
doing a remote debugging is not going to
help because debugging only captures
logs of the changes happening it does
not do anything with validating the
changes create a staging environment
could be or is the right answer because
when we have staging environments
anything that we run on production can
be run on staging environment and any
failures that would happen in production
if we simply run it in production can be
captured when we run the application in
the staging environment so that that way
staging environment is a very helpful
and useful service and that way I can
catch any errors in other words I can
validate the changes that were done by
my development team before I move it to
production and that reduces the downtime
in the production environment look at
this one last question that we have for
you it's a standard tier application is
used across the world and uses Azure
website standard tier it uses large
amount of image files so you can get it
this could be an e-commerce website
which has a lot of pictures in it and
this is causing the application to load
slow how can we handle this situation
let's look at the options given
configure blob storage with custom
domain well this application has
pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure Azure
website Auto scaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the CPU or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the CPU it's not the memory so
configure Azure for auto scaling is not
going to help and then what are the
other options let's see configure Azure
CDN to cache all responses from the
applications web endpoint a CDN could be
the right answer but look at that it
says a CDN to cache all responses from
the applications web endpoint CDN is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use CDN to
capture all responses from the
applications web endpoint the proper
design for CDN would be to Cache the
frequently used ones in other words cash
the static content which are photos
videos logos and pictures and lot more
on this static content that never
changes let's look at the last option
configure Azure CDN to Cache site images
and content stored in Azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application to store the
pictures high quality lazy loading or
slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in CDN and then the content
let it be stored in Azure blob storage
that's the right way of Designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
Azure full course I hope you found it
useful and entertaining please ask any
questions about the topics covered in
this video in the comments box below our
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems soon thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here